I don't know about all of you guys but I
think Joe Biden's not going to be
running for president in 2024. You Got a
New York Times article saying he
shouldn't run and he should tell
everyone he's not running you've got
vultures circling his withered decaying
body all these prominent individuals and
Democratic party are being lined up even
CNN's running an article saying the 11
Democrats who could replace Joe Biden
the media knows it it's time to admit it
Joe Biden is not going to make it to the
end of a second term he'd be eight what
86 I think is what they say in the New
York Times 86 years old and now we have
this
Joe Biden goes to Kentucky because of
the disaster and people are yelling at
him let's go Brandon they don't like
this guy people don't like this guy now
look I get it 60 some odd percent of
Democrats want him to run again only 60
percent independent voters mostly don't
Republicans obviously don't but he can't
even get more than 60 of his own party
dude's out so we'll we'll definitely
talk about this we're going to talk
about what's going on with the New York
City Banning uh gas buildings so they're
switching to all electricity and now
there's speculation that's going to
result in Rolling blackouts but uh I
guess that's what happens when you have
Democrat leadership in New York
unrestrained shutting down free speech
shutting down people's livelihoods
nobody cares I mean people fled I guess
but now that you've just given the
despots full control of the city and I
can't blame people for leaving joining
us to talk about all of this is Alicia
crossed did I say Krause totally wrong I
did the wrong one I did it for him it's
my bad though because everybody always
biffs my name and I was like oh it's
Elisha Kraus not Alicia cross and then I
think that was right before Oh and I
went I went I did the other wrong and
you did the wrong one because
and then it was stuck in your head so
I'm sorry about that that's your fault
that I said it wrong not my fault don't
look at me if if Tim's gonna say it
wrong I'm definitely gonna say it wrong
and it's not on purpose it's not mine
you can call me E Yeah Krauss my husband
calls me Elish oh that's cute Elisha uh
no we had this conversation I know so I
don't know if he was just pulling my leg
but when Ben and I did a Morning Show
together he informed me that I have a
Jewish dude's name and my parents are
like we're non-denominational and I like
you think that it's Elijah and Elijah in
the Bible and Ben was like no it's
Elijah and Elisha and I literally just
asked you I was like Krauss right I mean
you're like yeah and then you and then I
think you said oh you said what do you
say Alicia cross I said don't say cross
and then I did I did it oh so who are
you what do you do who am I what do I do
um I'm a out of work homeschool mom uh
yeah I uh no I uh live in Los Angeles
um a conservative commentator hey at
least it's sunny like true it's
dictatorial but the weather's nice and
uh and I'm a political geek that's been
doing this stuff in this world since I
was 18 I'm a grandma Millennial I'm 35.
and uh yeah I'm here in DC uh area
co-hosting at Newsmax this week so
that's been fun right on well thanks for
coming whatever I want to talk about
well thanks for having me as well my
name is Luke radowski and I think New
Hampshire is one of the best freest
places in the world next to Chiron
Mexico and that's why hey I made this
t-shirt that says make America New
Hampshire which you could get
exclusively on the
bestpoliticalshirts.com and because you
do I'm here thanks for having me I'm
excited to have this conversation with
someone's name that sounds like a Jewish
dude thanks so much yeah uh hey Ian
Crossland here from Ian crossland.net
happy to be here glad you guys are here
thanks for coming I'm excited to be here
as well pushing buttons in the corner as
I do and I love my lady guests as always
I'm excited for tonight as well yeah we
gotta balance out all the testosterone
seriously it's a struggle yeah Luke
Luke's preparing a fight club or
something I am and we got professional
kickboxer trainers in the house like a
real fight club tonight professional
tomorrow I don't know that I can do that
in my heels but I want to stress like
actual trained people are coming to do a
class and like teach people right I mean
if you're gonna have a fight club of the
first world is we can't talk
because I've already revealed too much
before we get started my friends go to
timcast.com become a member and help
support our Fierce and independent
journalism as a member you get access to
our members only segment we've got a ton
of segments from the Tim Castro podcast
that are exclusive available only on the
website timcast.com and you can watch
all of them as a member so please help
support our work because all of this
everything we do is funded by you guys
becoming members on the website we're
hiring more people we're launching new
shows we're gonna go see Spider-Man
tomorrow in the first show and which
means I got to work double time mainly
because I want to see Spider-Man I'm
super excited for it oh my your job's so
hard you have to go watch Spider-Man
well it means I have to work like twice
as much in the morning to make sure I
can get there on time because we're
doing an early showing so I can make it
back for the for the IRL show I'm still
eye rolling at you saying it's because
we have a new show we have a pop culture
show and that's fun we want to make sure
that uh the hosts of our show are you
know dang it know what's going on I wish
we had talked like I would be totally
fine with bashing Ben Affleck today if
y'all wanted to go down there oh hey
maybe maybe we'll get there but anyway
um as a member you're helping support
all the new shows we're doing and that's
one of the things we have to do so you
know we're willing to do the hard work
of going to see Spider-Man tomorrow
because uh uh because the work has to be
done but uh no we do the show and we're
all supported by you so don't forget to
become a member but uh smash the like
button right now subscribe to this
channel Tim Castile on YouTube Share the
show with your friends and uh let's jump
in to this first story literally right
here that we have right up people shout
let's go Brandon during Joe Biden's
visit to Kentucky and there's a picture
of Joe of Joseph I was going to say Joe
Brandon Joe Brandon sorry we just made
you you mess up on all the names like
once you've done one wrong you're just
gonna read that it's fine why are you
redowskiing so much what's going on here
maybe you know maybe I just haven't had
enough you know sugar or something yeah
I've zero sugar today yeah all right
President Joe Biden was met with shouts
of let's go Brandon and a trump flag as
he arrived in Kentucky on Wednesday to
survey damage from a tornado that killed
at least 88 people uh we know what let's
go Brandon means so they got videos and
photos two let's go Brandon's from the
crowd as Biden gets out after arriving
in the state Biden tweeted I'm in
Kentucky to meet with local leaders in a
survey the damage from the tornadoes in
extreme weather it will take all of us
working together to recover and begin
rebuilding and we are committed to
providing whatever support is needed for
however long it takes earlier in the day
Biden spoke with Kentucky Governor Andy
beshear and was briefed on the damage
while in Mayfield Department of Homeland
Security secretary Alejandro mayorcas
was also present and that's basically it
that's the gist of the story but I think
this is an important uh important story
yeah I feel like under the years of the
former president even like I I go back
to I'm a political nerd so even back to
like when Romney was running or McCain
was running or when George W Bush was in
the White House I remember living on
34th Street in New York City and half a
million people were like burning his
Effigies right and it was like a news
story of look how mad they are at the
Republican in office and and like
protesters Free Speech yay but it's also
one-sided like here's two dudes which
you know two dudes ain't that many I
feel like most the people in Kentucky
are probably legitimately mourning and
worried about their homes and their
neighbors and the businesses in the area
and what are they going to do with the
rest of their lives and their priority
isn't to go out there and yell let's go
Brandon but kudos to the guys who did
and they have a right to do that and and
so but you're not going to get coverage
of this anywhere else because heaven
forbid people who are against Joe Biden
expressed their you know viewpoints I
think they have a right to to say it I
think it's important that people speak
up especially in the face of Joe Biden I
think that's what makes America great
the fact that Joe Biden can come down
and you can yell let's go Brandon what's
awesome for sure and part of me is
though like man I wish we could kind of
just get like we have a major disaster
80 people died yeah but Joe Biden is
just he's burning this country to the
ground and I'm not going to blame him
for the natural disaster but so many
people are suffering in this country
because of his failed leadership for
someone to get that opportunity to be
like I am going to criticize you over
everything we're dealing with well and
if you look at that you got to do it
even NPR I think I was listening to NPR
earlier today and they were talking
about how this area was already hard hit
by the economy and then you have a
tornado that comes through and levels
the entire town so there is and this
guy's gonna do a photo op and he's and
that and so I get the frustration of
local people that are like okay now
you're coming now you're pretending to
do something now you're gonna send us
funds now you're pretending to care when
we've lost our factory jobs and we've
done all this stuff and like this quote
unquote return to normal that you
promised hasn't happened Well Middle
America has been I think most screwed
over by the establishment whether it was
the opioid epidemic whether it's even
gas prices going up this predominantly
affects people in rural rural areas like
Kentucky where they have to drive around
they spend more on gas they spend more
and on energy and utilities but this is
not a rare occurrence I still remember
at the end of the Bush presidency there
was also an incident where he was out
there surveying some kind of
environmental damage and then people
came up and screamed a few Bush they
also did it to Dick Cheney but his poll
numbers are extremely down and I think
the few people who are supporting him
are some cartel members the tally band
and a few billionaires that really make
up the few percentage points of support
that he gets and China yeah yes yes good
big fan taking it taking advantage right
now he's meeting with Putin and they're
basically joining together because Biden
is is
well it's look I don't want war in
Ukraine I don't want war in Afghanistan
but Joe Biden wow did he screw up
Afghanistan and that's really when his
poll numbers took a huge hit because he
he's he's a failed leader I think with a
lot of stuff especially inflation the
reason people are mad at the
establishment altogether yeah a lot of
people are in these cities and they they
can't see it they don't understand when
the prices go up a little bit they're
not thinking about it and it's
incremental if every day you wake up
they add you know a nickel or whatever
to the food it's going to take you a
little while to be like hey wait a
minute why is the milk costing so much
but when you get news story like people
are screaming and dying and a bomb went
off in Afghanistan and our you know the
the withdrawal was a huge disaster
all of a sudden people there's something
tangible they can see there I gotta say
though I think for average Americans
outside the Beltway outside you know
these liberal meccas where everybody's
making a quarter of a million dollars a
year and they're like stem jobs right
um that you have people like me that I
go to the grocery store every week with
my kids and that does affect us fuel
prices do affect us my parents lives 30
miles from the closest grocery store you
have people watching right now that you
know have to commute maybe 50 miles to
work one day uh one way and so those
things even though it is like
incremental they still feel that when
they look at their paycheck and they're
like well that thousand bucks ain't
gonna go as far this week and I think
that that angst can continue into the
midterms but I don't know voters have
short-term memory and obviously his
ratings are not good his his polling
numbers are not too hot and I don't I
don't blame they're absolutely so bad
um but I think that there's an element
of most of the time people vote with
what affects them like in that moment
voting is an emotional appeal and
typically liberals tend to do a better
job at telling a story but the story
that they're telling the story that
they're showing and the story that
they're governing right now is a total
crap show and and I think it's going to
really hurt them next year what I think
is absolutely crazy is that Biden's
approval rating was as high as it was
for as long as it was especially
compared to Trump when we got Donald
Trump in office the economy started
doing better in 2019 I heard over and
over again how good the economy was from
from news reports from individuals when
we were buying furniture for the first
Studio we built the furniture sales lady
was just like 2019 was the greatest year
of my life I can't believe how much
money I made I'm so happy the guy who
was doing the um foundation work as we
were expanding outside he was like
business is booming and that was January
of 2020. yep and then what happened yeah
but take a look what's really
fascinating we have this Joe Biden's
Real Clear Politics poll average it's
right around it's Afghanistan yeah where
he really got slammed yeah and that's
why it's fascinating to me that it was
literally screwing up getting out of
Afghanistan where things start to flip
and I think what may have happened is
that moment was a big slap in the face
to a lot of people who are who are
content to be like Trump is gone
everything's fine yeah and then all of a
sudden they were like a bomb just went
off and killed a bunch of people outside
of the the airport yeah Air Force Base
was abandoned and I think left right or
Center even like you said okay I didn't
want to be in war in Afghanistan you
don't want to abandon our own people and
there is thank God this beauty to
America and our citizens that whether
you look like me or vote like me I'm
still not gonna like abandon you in
another country well like and I'm not
going to lead you to die and I think
that there has been this element of your
commander-in-chief does not leave you
behind there's you know all of the
situations like Reagan with the Iran
hostages you know other situations of
even Obama who paid to get some people
out of Iran that like we we don't leave
our guys behind we don't leave our
people behind and it was a wake-up call
and I think very shocking to a lot of
Americans like holy wait what this just
happened and nobody's gonna do anything
about it and they're just pretending
like it's no big deal I was surprised
the moment people didn't wake up was
truing it on a shop of pressure yeah
well the mainstream media pretty much
got him into office they're supporting
him throughout the way but now that you
see the cracks uh in the facade that
they kind of painted of him as this kind
of trump savior he's not a trump savior
what happened in Afghanistan was an
absolute geopolitical failure that of
course gave billions of dollars of
Weaponry to the Taliban and their
retaliation against the attack on the
base was literally killing 10 innocent
civilians seven of them children U.S Aid
workers that were providing water and
just recently as of a few hours ago the
Pentagon announced that they will be
holding no one responsible for the
Butcher and assassination of innocent
civilians in Afghanistan that the media
and the Pentagon were telling us was
Isis K members that were going to launch
a preemptive strike on the embassy that
wasn't true they were lying through
their teeth and this is one reason why
again Biden totally out of touch with
reality he had to have a PR campaign
disinformation group to meeting with the
corporate media in order to paint a
positive picture on the economy wow and
and today he even issued statement
saying what's the big deal when talking
about giving up freedoms in exchange for
of course the vaccine mandates totally
out of touch totally totalitarian to me
he's a puppet ID that many special
interests are using to push very
unpopular policies on the American
people did he get a command man in there
when he said to give up your freedom
nope
clearly yeah
and he was like you know what's up
the more dictatorial he is the clearer
he speaks I'm old enough to remember my
background has been talk radio and I
produce the Hannity radio show for seven
years and I remember there was a time
where it was like Hugh Hewitt might have
been Dennis Prager Mark Levin Sean
Hannity like the ogs of conservative
right radio met with George W bush in
his second term and it might have been a
time when his poll numbers were down and
there was like all of these mainstream
media reports once the meeting was
leaked of oh look white house conspires
with far-right media and like try to
boost the president's poll numbers but
yet you have like you said not just not
just you know The Young Turks and like
crazy leftist organizations that claim
to be unbiased media Outlets uh going
and talking to people in the White House
communications team you have members of
the mainstream media Outlets that
pretend to be
fair and balanced journalists that are
doing this and like where is the outrage
just I think the double standard is what
really gets to me there's two things
I'll add first is there was a CNN
producer who was arrested for
trafficking kids and Brian stelter's on
Twitter like why won't the fox hosts
talk about the text messages and it's
like they did well it was 24 hours later
and it's like when are you gonna talk
about the criticism yeah Chris Cuomo I'm
your producer the producer who worked
with Chris or even the CIA Scandal where
they caught their own agents doing some
of those same similar actions but MSNBC
ABC News CBS NBC all ignored this major
CNN producer but I got to add one more
thing too about what happened in
Afghanistan I'll tell you where I think
I wish more Americans would give Biden a
lower rating is when he what did he do
he did it he issued a drone strike which
killed 10 civilians was it 10 10
civilians seven children and it was an
aid worker that was providing clean
water to The Afghani people and uh how
many of the uh is anybody involved going
to be I don't know maybe indicted go to
prison or the Pentagon just announced no
one will be responsible for this action
so Joe Biden following his predecessor
Barack Obama
kills children now I'm not going to give
Trump a a an escape on this one the
difference is with with Barack Obama we
know definitively that he killed Abdul
Rahman alawlaki in a drone strike in
Yemen we know definitively that Joe
Biden's Administration they issued this
drone strike when it comes to Donald
Trump and the death of Abdul rahman's
little sister this is this is a Commando
raid in Yemen it's speculated that she
died it's it's so it's still bad and I
don't want to give Trump any free passes
on passes on his drone strikes or his
Commando raids and the and the stuff he
did but I'm also going to say Donald
Trump also moved to withdraw from
Afghanistan and Syria and and didn't
start any new Wars and I'll take what I
can get criticism where criticism is due
praise where praise is due Joe Biden I
knew this was going to happen you get
him in office and he was going to
restart the war machine the same we saw
in the in the Years prior one I think
that we all kind of expected that in
2016 had it been Hillary Clinton who won
and I think that that's why you saw
people
um specifically like those Rust Belt
people where Hillary didn't spend any
money
um yeah you know that decided to vote
for Trump because it was a breath of
fresh air and people were War weary now
as someone who knows and loves many
members of the military I don't know the
details of that Commando thing and I've
never been on the ground with a gun to
my head and having to kill bad guys and
unfortunately there is a cost-benefit
analysis to every single decision that
you make as commander-in-chief right
like if you actually it is kind of
fascinating to go back and look at the
Obama decision to go get in Bin Laden
and how the guys in the room all had
different percentages of what they
thought the likelihood of one Bin Laden
actually being there and then two it
being like a no-fault operation and the
and that that risk is extremely high and
that's part of their job but yeah I do
appreciate the consistency that you have
there it's just also once again the
media would be blowing up everything had
an aid worker been killed in a drone
strike by how much but just really quick
there wasn't a lot of consistency with
the official story of what Obama did to
uh Osama and then it the raid that
Donald Trump committed that allegedly
killed anawaki's sister uh was literally
the raid that Obama didn't want to do
but but Donald Trump personally called
off on and there was civilian casualties
according to many independent reports
I'll say this though that was really
early in in Trump's Administration Trump
switched to to getting American
Personnel out and upping drone strikes
I'm not a big fan of that necessarily
but I suppose it's like what do you do
right you you say we don't want ground
conflict so to secure certain areas you
need drones
Donald Trump tried getting us out of
Syria and he was lied to by whatever
whatever you want to call these people
you know uh the bureaucratic State how
about that the administrative State they
lied to the American people and to
Donald Trump to make sure that that we
kept troops in Syria when he and the
American people don't want these wars so
I will give him credit for that and I
will I will say this speaking of Hillary
Clinton
we're just really quick also I want to
add that Donald Trump made sure that the
list of people that were assassinated by
the drone strikes was Kept Secret away
from the general public Obama at least
executed people kept the list uh let's
be honest with each other but but Trump
also took away the decision for him
personally calling off on these
assassinations and gave it to the
Pentagon as well so I think that's an
important factor to to understand here
and I wish he would have pulled troops
out correctly out of Afghanistan but you
mean like you want the transparency of
it yes exactly and Reporting like if
you're going to kill a 15 year old
American citizen which Obama did and his
spokesperson told me and and we are
changed reporters that they should have
had a better father at least be open and
transparent about it that was that was
massive that was back about 2012. yep
that was during the presidential
election Luke was on the ground during
the election campaign and he you went up
to I think Debbie Wasserman Schultz and
who was it Charlie Gibbs uh yes Charlie
Gibbs and Obama's uh chief of staff and
and spokesperson and I asked him exactly
why did your Administration personally
call off on the assassination of a 15
year old
signed off on the on the assassination
of a 15 year old American citizen and
the response I got by by Mr Gibbs was he
should have had a better father this
this actually got that's a this was an
American how did I forget that story
like that's like in my but that that's
that's not just Obama you know of course
he was the president but that's Biden
too Biden was it was very deeply
involved in the in the in the Iraq
operation oh he likes to it's funny how
remember uh did bin Laden's dead
Detroit's alive yeah I don't know you've
been to Detroit lately like he very much
liked to marry himself to all of the
wins of the Obama Administration I think
mainly to appeal to Black voters
um and not it's not bury himself to any
of the failures of the Obama's
administration of which there are many
well it's this is this has been an
abysmal abysmal uh Administration and
it's only it's not it's not even been a
full year so we're already getting this
check this out we're already getting
rumors that Joe Biden is not going to be
running in 2024. so who do you think it
might be could it be Hillary Clinton no
The Daily Mail reports Clinton's belief
that the presidency is her Birthright
and deep unpopularity of Biden and
Harris could see the former first lady
run in 2024 politics in cider warns and
I do not disagree I don't know if I
believe she would because she is deeply
unpopular herself but she came out
recently and she was like here's the
speech I would have given if I won could
you just give me a second to rant about
that by the way when on God's green
earth has anyone lost as much as Hillary
Clinton and been given so much time to
talk about all the things that she
wanted to do or would have done had she
won like Democrats in general fail up
like Pete wouldn't judge anybody but I
am just fascinated by the fact that we
keep giving this like what was she on
the Today Show or something like it was
a legitimate mainstream media show with
millions of viewers where like she's
given a prime time a block slot to talk
about here's the speech I would have
given okay here's the speech I would
have given had I been born Gisele
Bundchen had I been yeah exactly had I
gotten an Oscar here's the speech I
would have given isn't she doing a
master class or something yeah
right now my favorite my favorite joke I
saw was someone said what's the master
class going to be pointing out Wisconsin
on a map
that's the one she would need Standing
By Your Man
having great relationships winning
elections well um now let's be real
those are things she was all really bad
at but she could but the media pretends
that she is good at all right right it's
like they give her the opportunity to
give that dumb speech but I gotta give
her because they feel like she should
have given that speech and they also are
signed on to it being hurt yes yes but
as much as many people don't like
Hillary Clinton and I'm not a fan I
think we absolutely need to recognize
what she is really really good at the
things she's done really well like
running the Clinton Foundation while she
was running the state department and
taking donations from foreign
governments to large sums and then all
of a sudden when she was no longer a
contender for the presidency or in the
White House those donations started out
I got another one I got another one I
got another one I just got one really
quick one making sure that her husband
goes on the Epstein's Island he's very
good at that the the Maxwell trial I
follow all the conspiracy theorists on
the Graham about that but uh yeah she's
also really good at just signing on
Hollywood money and Hollywood
celebrities and
going and partying and stuff she's great
being connected to Harvey Weinstein as
well I mean yeah yeah well that's a job
she knows how to pick them did you see
that you saw the video of her crying
right it was the weirdest not cry like
fake crying I'm sorry they came out and
you know everyone ragged on Cal
Rittenhouse saying crocodile tears and
I'm like the dude's having a panic
attack anything but like that was PTSD
that kid needs to be I will say this
he's getting therapy because okay thank
you because I the mom and me is like
stopped doing interviews start doing
therapy right he is he that was the
trial because you are young and in 10
years
it's gonna hit you you need to you need
to take a beat I feel like someone
should have told that to Hillary when
she was much younger yeah because
something is wrong with her something
something from a very young age so did
did your mom ever tell you like you Tim
you can be whatever you want to be like
there's moms like they are unconditional
they're amazing they encourage you so
did my mom she's probably watching right
now hey Mom and and like Alicia you can
be anything you want to be but it's like
did Hillary's mom do that to the nth
degree yeah too much like just too much
like was it weirdly indoctrinated like
did she have goggles on that it was like
fed to her like in Zoolander like this
is what you will do this is what you
will do and that's why she I genuinely
thinks it's her birthday
no no the one the reason I don't think
so is because her mom uh has a goat's
head and you know oven feet and Claws
and clothing you know created her out of
a pentagram and summoned her from the
depths and probably just you know intent
was it was in inherent Within the
Demonic president yeah I was going to
say something similar MK Ultra I think
that's also a possibility
but uh who knows but it's over time
exactly but no she's just she's just in
she's just an insane person you know
she's she's a sociopath narcissistic yes
yeah ego narcissism I think I think
actually left right under Center I think
in order to be honestly
um I think most people in in our
industry so politicians and anybody on a
microphone is typically narcissistic
she's on record celebrating death and
murder and torture she's like yeah that
was great remember when she said she
wanted to drone Julian Assange can't we
just drown this guy and then she was
like it was a joke I swear yeah yeah but
when McCain said bom bom bom bom bom
Iran in a q a in 2008 people were like
what warmonger neocon so is it yeah is
it because you think Hillary's gonna run
I I don't know I kind of would be
excited for it the hill because she
would lose miserably miserably Trump
would just win again there's gonna be a
glitch in The Matrix and we wake up and
as soon as election season starts we're
back in 2016 we don't know what happened
and it's Hillary versus Trump again it's
like what no no it's Ian waking up and
he's he was like coming out of a DMT
trip I remember the moment I woke up and
saw Trump won and I felt like the wind
was knocked out of me I was like what
what's happened like what did I drink
yeah I guess for sure it was like
totally I was in Times Square and you
could hear a pin drop and all the people
that went there to celebrate were all
quiet there was like five Trump
supporters and you could see Five Guys
and everyone's just giving them the
stink eye and I was there filming it
like this is absolutely crazy and
incredible at the same time was it the
crying meme like the crazy yeah the
crying meme filled with people in Times
Square like people shocked Jaws on the
floor walking around aimlessly lost like
zombies not knowing what just hit them
and they're watching all the news like
in total it was it was it was something
to experience it's a night I will never
forget when I watch The New York Times
Like probability meter it said like
greater than 99 chance Hillary Clinton
and then it slowly went down I remember
when it hit 50 yeah and I was just I was
laughing I was in the Sputnik office and
everyone there started like people were
starting to cry because they were all
Democrats and then it shifts and then I
remember when it was like Trump is
cannot lose at this point Cassandra
Fairbanks is there she's laughing she
went from crying to laughing to crying
again because it was like sad crying and
then like in the denial I do have to say
so I'm a home birth hippie and uh I like
went to this unfortunately Cove had
closed down my liberal friends yoga
studio and it was like women only so I
really liked it because I feel like we
were doing yoga yeah dudes and um and
there were a lot of women in like the
full Women Health yoga class like the
next day that were like I'm just here
for the piece
and I did all of my Essential Oils on
all of my touch points chunk ooger
freaking out like during his life it was
hilarious it was crazy I just sitting
there like guys okay they're like Alicia
what's stressing you today and I'm like
oh you guys
what I find funny too is like my
response to the election with Joe Biden
was I was like there it is the cat is in
Joe Biden you know is projected to be
the winner and then they they got mad at
me for that like the the Liberals were
like haha you're a loser and I'm like I
just was like yeah he won I don't know
you stated truth I mean Trump supporters
got mad at me you know when I said that
but I'm just like it is what it is I
don't know what am I supposed to do
about it and they were like haha you're
a loser you voted for Trump and you lost
and I was like yeah
I do have to say and I was reading
something the other day as a mom and I
think like it's good for society in
general like we have to learn how to
lose like you have to be a good you have
to be decent at losing to understand the
importance of winning and I think that
if you don't learn that like Hillary did
it well let's shut up dude just shut up
it is you're not being graceful and
you're not being dignified and you're
not doing the country any good and like
if you want to run for president of the
United States you're allegedly supposed
to care about country first it's clearly
not about country first but it's going
to be okay because a lot of women are
going to learn how to lose at Sports in
sports especially ourselves
yeah yeah well I I it's it's man it's
crazy to me it's been 60 it's been six
and a half years since I'm like sitting
there watching Hillary Clinton
announcing she's gonna run and then the
2016 election cycle when she's debating
Trump was one of the funniest things
ever that you know the things because
you'd be in jail it's like man and mic
drop moments people are cheering they're
treating it like WWE the the debates
were definitely more entertaining I used
all the gifs in my tweets from the
debates like so fun are never fun or
funny but Donald Trump he brought that
and so so I actually had this
conversation the other day with somebody
uh Trump also brought I think like the
cable newsification to politics like
I've often said that the Trump family is
like the Royals meet the Kardashians
because because like that is the kind of
cultural phenomenon that they are and
that he kind of had a thing like they
had hair and makeup people in the white
house for anyone in their Administration
that went on camera he kind of got that
the visual and the story it mattered and
that's why Hollywood is all about
leftism for a few other things too but
because it's like they are turned to and
have been turned to for decades to
create the narrative and to create the
story to help Democrats win and
Republicans have often failed at like
the emotion and the story of things well
this is something that Andrew Clayton
talks a lot about he talks about how
conservatives are so bad at turning the
story in their favor we don't understand
the importance of the Arts we don't
understand the importance of movies or
books or anything like that that's part
of the reason that we're losing the
culture wars is something that the left
has such a grasp on I don't know why
we're so bad at it but I think that for
a really long time we have fled because
we thought that we couldn't win there so
then we flee I mean we see it happening
now with covid right self-fulfilling
profit people just they run away they go
to the ease of things instead of like
putting down roots and fighting and
being the odd man out
Trump a lot of people think Trump's
going to run right yeah we know we've
even talked to Steve bannon's like he's
running it's going to happen and some of
his former Administration and uh I
certainly think so he's been rallying
he's been losing weight I guess but I
mean he's going to be up there too I
mean he's going to be he's gonna be as
old as Joe Biden was when Joe Biden ran
so he'll be like the second oldest
president ever and he did have that line
against Biden about how Biden was too
old and yeah but is that anymore Trump
is spry yeah I've heard that about him
yeah one criticism that I'm seeing a lot
of him especially when he goes on Fox
news is that he's actually supporting a
big Pharma more than his supporters I've
seen a lot of criticism of him
especially with a lot of the the
mandates and and that he criticizes a
little bit but he still promotes overall
well did he consider it a mandate I
thought early in covid he was like oh
yeah well we should we should have like
a incentive and we should make sure that
everybody gets the vaccine there's also
a lot of criticism from his base uh of
people saying that he just didn't stand
up for his supporters for his people and
that there's a huge kind of Disconnect
between a lot of people who are not
really satisfied with that
Administration as well that needs to be
brought up I think that the number one
um well I don't know I look at 2024 and
I'm like let's just run to santis then
we can have a really fun like Lottery of
who we go and choose for VP and then
just like destroy any of the what was it
11 different Democrats and all of the
Democrats at the mainstream media is
floating all of the names are awful and
they're all losers once again Democrats
fail up it was like none of these people
have have the in fact who is who Amy
Klobuchar okay
um okay DeSantis has a lot of good
energy behind him he does yes and so I'm
just saying like I would love it I would
love it if if people like any other like
Republican that's thinking of running
anybody like Abbott anybody else Under
the Sun just I love you guys you're
great keep keep governing well in your
States let's just give it to DeSantis
and then we can have one of you great
people as VP and then we can destroy any
of these idiots on this list we I think
DeSantis is a better option although he
is more of a traditional Republican in a
lot of ways yes so for me you know we'll
see it really is dependent It's gotta
it's gonna be about what's in the
Forefront of his administration and I'm
still kind of skeptical Trump I didn't
vote for the first time after seeing
what he was doing I was like this guy's
a bow in a china shop and he's saying no
to the establishment DeSantis however I
think has proven himself especially with
the with kovid so if he were to run I
gotta say too I'm really impressed with
a lot of these AGS on the state level
yeah like
um a lot of these attorney generals like
in Oklahoma for example they're kind of
like oh you can't mandate date our
National Guard to have the jab because
turns out we're in charge of the
National Guard not the dod so there you
go and and I and I really I'm pretty
impressed with a lot of these like AGS
on some State levels and maybe they'll
end up in the senate or something one
day that'd be nice let's let's talk
about what Rhonda Santos is doing and
one of the things that I would really
really support him over and this is from
The Washington Post DeSantis invokes MLK
as he proposes stop woke act against
critical race Theory I'm a fan they say
is Florida Governor Ron DeSantis was
introducing proposed legislation that
would allow parents to sue schools
teaching critical race theory in the
classroom he invoked the words of
Reverend Martin Luther King Jr that's Dr
Martin Luther King Jr to try and make
his point about the stop woke Act and
the escalating conflict over the
teaching of race you see how they did
that to drink race yeah okay nice try
quote you think about what MLK stood for
he said he didn't want people judged on
the color of their skin but on the
content of their character de Santa said
you listen to some of these people
nowadays they don't talk about that so I
tell you this the one thing I always ask
my liberal friends I say something very
very simply simple to them I say uh do
you support the message of Dr King
yes yeah oh of course absolutely yeah
and then I'll say what about segregating
these classrooms on the basis of race is
in line with judging people on the
content of their character not the color
of their skin yeah and it for a lot of
people there's a cognitive dissonance
they get angry because they're very
tribalist slow because it's not fair
this is like the instant reaction well
they say they say colorblind Society is
wrong and I'm like so you don't agree
with with Dr King what Rhonda Santos is
doing is what I wanted I wanted Trump to
be doing the the left establishment lies
about what critical race theory is to
try and inject this into our society Joe
Biden gets rid of Trump's you know
executive order bans on critical race
Theory training and the leftists who are
in many ways populists many of them
aren't support this because this is a
precursor to a form of Communism or or a
path towards class instruction you can
bring that about yes
I think if MLK was alive today this
might be a little bit hyperbolic but I
think he would be villainized and
slandered by the corporate media I think
he would be Shadow band on big Tech
social media what's this phrase so I
will put quotes around it but but he
would be called by liberals Uncle Tom
or a white supremacist or well we have
seen people who use words literally be
called that but look at look at how they
treat any member of a group whether you
are a woman like myself well I can't
they're yes all woman until it comes to
a woman like me right or they are
um for minorities unless you happen to
be Ben Carson or Alan West or Conor
Candace Owens or you know they're for
the lgbtq people unless you're Dave
Rubin was like it's everything has like
a stop point for them because it is it
is the ideology and the agenda was was
MLK
anti-lgbtq I'm not sure but I was
reading something I'm not entirely sure
the FBI had a lot of dirt on him showing
that he had extramarital Affairs that
they were using against him they
literally sent evidence of that to his
wife when he was in prison as the FBI
was sending MLK letters telling him to
kill himself in prison as they were
extorting him politically with these
larger bigger truths that they got on
him after spying on him he was a part of
the church and he was preaching that
kind of church lifestyle uh he was a
reverend
um I love how like if you believe in the
biblical definition of marriage like I
myself believe that now that's just like
dubbed anti-gay yeah and and he did have
extramarital Affairs and because of that
the FBI that was spying on him got that
information and was literally trying to
use it so he would kill himself that's
the that's the history of the FBI the
institution that now has all of
Epstein's secret files and videotapes
and and uh
conspiracy theories okay so I think
that's not true I think that's not true
I want to make sure yeah I don't but he
was a member of the church and he he
preached a lot in church and he was also
let's let's be fair he was also attacked
by the corporate media back then
um he wasn't seen as someone who is
extremely popular only after he died was
he was he seen as someone who was
popular and then kind of became more
popular by the day well that's typically
most leaders right and I think that from
a Evangelical background like I think
the beauty of actual history and the
beauty of religious history is that it
shows the innate sin that we were all
born into now nobody is perfect and so
it's it's actually I was homeschooled
all 12 years I'm now a homeschool mom to
an eight four and two-year-old and uh
it's fascinating to me that right around
the time the CRT stuff started coming up
I was reading about like turn of the
century post-civil War like
post-oppression era pre-civil Rights
Movement
um Americans with my now eight-year-old
like Roll of Thunder Hear My Cry is her
favorite book and I'm like this is stuff
that I learned like I learned real
American history The Good the Bad and
the Ugly you know who hasn't been
learning it for the last 30 years kids
in public schools why are they not
learning it because of lazy teachers
unions that I could go after and so it's
fascinating to me that people just have
this thing where they assume that
everyone is supposed to be perfect and I
think really the problem boils down to
politically culturally pop culturally
whatever people just put people on a
pedestal that should not be there I
think this issue is is a very it's it's
right for Ron DeSantis to tackle it this
way Donald Trump did the critical race
Theory ban but they didn't they didn't
call it that they used very specific
language and what's fascinating When
Donald Trump issued the executive order
Banning these trainings he was following
existing law the 1964 Civil Rights Act
says you cannot discriminate on the
basis of race as one of its you know one
of its many titles and what was
happening at these these government
contractors was they were having
whiteness tray like anti-whiteness
trainings and there was one I think it
was the nuclear laboratory not which one
uh we're not sure super duper important
by the way like when you're working
around nukes so this is Christopher on
the atomic scale race race matters right
and they they made the white men go to
like some Retreat to learn about like
you you can't do that that violates the
law so Trump comes out and says hey guys
this breaks the law don't do it Joe
Biden comes in says come on man break
the law any and he just undoes the
executive order and I'm like this is
insanity so Ron DeSantis is stepping up
with this we'll see what you know if if
he does end up running it's tough to say
I mean if if Trump ends up running do
you think DeSantis would actually run
against them I do you do I do I would
support the Santa's over Trump I think
it's the census's only chance if he
doesn't run that's that's going to be
the the you know where a lot of people
aren't going to be following him and
supporting him after that because this
is his only chance really and honestly
like Trump can only sorry like uh Trump
can only blame like the state so much
for the early covet policy that he
implemented right so anybody any
Republican or independent or even
Democrat who runs against him can
literally look at all of the edicts that
he had two weeks to solve the spread
yeah
would be standing next to Donald Trump
on a debate stage and he would say you
know with all due respect Mr President
for the good work you did I would have
fired fauci on day one exactly and
everyone's gonna go yeah and that's true
any Republican that runs against Trump
that's all they have to say is why did
you keep fauci in you were knocking him
but you had the authority to get rid of
him why didn't you do that you wouldn't
do it I think it was was it Kushner I
think yeah I can't remember who we were
talking to they were like he was advised
not to do it really yeah he was advised
to keep him around he's too popular you
got to keep him there was a trump
Horsemen of the White House that Peter
Navarro was telling us I don't know if
this was on the after segment or during
the the the time that he was on but he
talked about it four individuals that
were telling him to keep fauci there and
that it would be better for Trump to uh
to keep him what a mistake well we got
to see what Rhonda sand is willing to do
in in other areas awokeness is not a
reason for me to solely support somebody
yeah but I will say or mandates or yeah
but but I I gotta admit when it comes to
covid I would love I remember back when
I was telling you about 2019 it was so
fast it was so great man do you guys
remember what life was like before the
start of the pandemic it was amazing I
could actually go speak on college
campuses and have real life protesters
flying all over the world just checking
out crazy but Florida Florida is still
like that yeah Florida is normal yeah
Texas for the most part is as well by
the way my time in DC surprisingly I've
not uh I put on a mask in an Uber once
and only because the driver asked me and
I respect that when they ask I don't
even know what my rating is because I
just get into Ubers all the time on mass
um less masking in DC than La what's the
um what's the uh the courtesy with masks
and Uber do you get an unmasked and only
mask up if they ask or do you get in
with the mask I lie I tell a little lie
when I it's like do you have a mask I'm
like well I have a mask but I'm not
wearing a mask because you have to check
that button before you can order it
literally have you you uh you have to
wear three masks and then when you get
in you can ask the driver how many are
allowed to take off and if he tells you
to wear it may I just robe sir okay
[Laughter]
I am very glad I don't know who here is
in relationships or not but like I've
been married for 12 years and I'm so
grateful that I like found my husband
got married young because like I could
not date today but then I talked to
friends or like reads random like
threads and stuff online about people
that date there was this one girl she
was like yeah we were having like
something training at the bar where I
work and this guy like had he was tall
he was fit you know had a good voice
asked me out and then they went out
after work and where they could take off
their masks oh no and she was like he
was better with the mask oh no yeah take
a look at this take a look at this we
have this video oh yeah this video went
viable dating in 2021 yeah let me see if
I can what kind of that guy's the
epitome of high test time look at that
face so good so it's clear that this
guy's wife were saying to another wants
to wear they're wearing these big
plastic tubes but they're holding hands
they're like dogs
like after a dog gets you know what
that's what he is okay so I just gotta
explain to people people who can't see
it or just listening there is a woman
and a man this is a report I think from
RT and the woman is happy she's showing
off that she's wearing a dog cone it's
effectively a duck owned but the guy's
face is just he's like he's literally
Smiles
that's like a live shot of me anytime
Gavin Newsom says that he's extending
the mask
Hi man just like bro by the way she's
way too pretty for him yes and that's
and he knows it and he knows and that's
why he's doing it look at she's watch
this she does like she she's twirling oh
I don't like she what are you Cinderella
and then it shows look at that taking
pictures and then look at the guy's face
he's just she's not too pretty memorable
she's too crazy for him that's what they
call smile when you're not happy yeah
I think this is in Europe but I just
want to tell this man my friend
Florida yeah it's a real place he'll be
like no don't so is it true the floor is
it not really like last year when I left
the show the first day I got into
Florida they had a mask burning at the
beach that's amazing huge parties down
in Fort Lauderdale and I I went down
there and I literally didn't even unpack
my RV I was like I need to see this I
need to see what's going on here huge
parties huge clubs huge bars everyone's
partying and there's like hundreds of
people on the beach and they're all just
taking their mask literally burning them
on fire being like we're not going to
comply with this absolutely nothing you
can't do that in California because then
you're like contributing to the bad
environment right so I feel like telling
that guy like some people have low T
because of age you have low T because of
that thing that you're wearing yeah so I
wanted to I'll bring it back to Rhonda
santis and that that humor is exactly
why I'm like that to me is is leadership
we also have to like he has been under
Fire for a year and a half now almost
two years I cannot believe this but like
in March we will be at the two year mark
from when all this craziness began and
and he has been consistent he has not
count out he has not given up they
haven't found anything on him as much as
they have tried and I think that he has
handled it really brilliantly
I'm a fan well the corporate media said
that he was going to going to be the
Butcher of Florida that there's going to
be a bloodbath that bodies were going to
be piling on top of bodies
though that was because it was because
of his you know uh elderly home policy
but the the amount of criticism that he
was able to withstand from the national
media attacking him is not noteworthy
and
um it's really going to be interesting
to see him tee off against Trump which I
think is going to happen no one else Ron
yeah they're gonna fight each other
they got a WWE it up the two of them
together should coordinate no matter who
wins and make it the biggest spectacle
on Earth just a Florida the hot Florida
action non-stop ego's gonna tell us that
sounds like a spring break tease
otherwise the corporate media is going
to overtake them and pump their
candidate and put Hillary in I mean they
have to work together otherwise but
here's the beauty though of New Media
like here's the beauty of what you guys
do like like the beauty of my phone that
I can go to and and people have the
ability like it isn't just the two fours
and sevens anymore right it's not the
three channels where you get all of your
information that my parents or my
grandparents thought whatever we had
three five and eight yeah we had two we
had two five nine it was 32. it's like
four four was always Fox seven was
always ABC okay
ABC for us in Chicago two was CBS five
was NBC nine was WGN and
WGN yeah WGN Fox 32 back in the day but
uh so so look look I want to explain why
um we have another story I'll talk about
why DeSantis approaching this woke stuff
is so important we have a story here
from Daily Mail this is an ongoing saga
about a transgender swimmer
demolishing female records the email
reports exclusive the Integrity of
women's sports is at stake distressed
parents of UPenn swimmers pen poignant
letter demanding the NCAA change rules
that have permitted transgender athlete
Thomas to dominate the competition good
for those parents good for those parents
especially so I I think the issue Right
Here Right Now the I don't I don't take
issue with with um on the surface with
Leah Thomas competing because the rules
were set and people did not participate
in the rule changes or what was going on
but but were they even aware that's
their fault so
yep I don't know people I understand
what you're saying and as somebody who's
super duper involved there's still stuff
that's happening that like that I'm
unaware of and I'm a political nerd
that's like doing stuff all the time how
many years have we been talking about
this and yeah but do you think that
these UPenn parents listen to you to you
some of them maybe maybe
but I think that you cannot you can't
assume that I don't I think it is a
wrong assumption to take that the
average parent who is working two jobs
to send their kid to you Penn
um is is really aware of oh hey the NCAA
changed rules that's interesting you
know that the left is so good at
sneaking this [ __ ] in most and they do
it
all the laws sure sure that's besides
the point look if you were a parent and
you are dedicating you are you were
talking about the lives of your children
and you are like I'm gonna send you to a
school and I don't know what the rules
are I don't know when the meetings are I
don't know the rule changes are
happening then I feel like you are being
you pen changes they were these were
NCAA changes like find this out because
I would be curious to know like was it
public and no because stuff like this
happens then they should have
immediately the moment they went into
that swim meet or whatever that right
and there was a dude and they just said
nope nope nope nope nope we're not doing
this what's going on and they didn't
they said just compete anyway and these
female swimmers are are not standing up
and speaking out they're just giving
Anonymous comments if you're not gonna
stand up for yourself if you're not
going to speak out about this and if you
are a parent who doesn't know look when
it comes to the NCAA we're talking about
your child's future we're talking about
how you have been coaching your child
and putting in a program to make them
the best of the best in whatever sport
they're engaged in and you don't know
about what's going on I'm sorry after
how many years has it been that we've
been having these conversations you
still don't know negligence but at this
point isn't it the parent they're adults
now these these students that's right
the parents responsibility anymore I
think that's true but it's the parent's
dollars right maybe and maybe in this
condition unless they took out a loan
eighty thousand dollars take a look
that's insane everybody is scared the
mom added parents are all are also
scared the kids will be harmed we are
paying eighty thousand dollars for the
school their life will be impacted that
wouldn't be the case if you would just
stand up and say no but we've had three
of three female swimmers come out
anonymously and be like we don't like
this but let's let's future trip here a
little bit what happens then because I'm
definitely a person that I'm fine with
standing up and saying no I am the
person I have dug my political grave I
will lie in it but part of what I do is
I feel like I have to be and I am
representative of women in stem and in
Hollywood and in fashion and in finance
who will legitimately lose everything if
they speak up and say no and I think
that you are now especially the heck yay
for Virginia with the youngin situation
seeing people that are saying okay
especially when it comes to our kids
enough is enough
I think that for these parents you can't
underestimate that them writing a letter
to the administration that could behind
the scenes or very publicly much to the
cheering of the sjws of the world how
many years though Tim has been going on
for a decade over a decade Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan Joe Rogan on his show Joe Rogan on
his show and this is back in 2012 talked
about Fallon Fox crushing a woman's
skull in an MMA ring Joe Rogan is the
biggest podcast in the world this is
mainstream and these parents had there's
there's no way you will ever convince me
they didn't know this is happening the
only reason they're speaking on this
letter is because it's finally impacting
them and now they have that's most
people most people don't say or do
anything like those women in in Virginia
once again that voted for youngin that
also voted for Joe Biden they flipped in
the last two weeks because it affected
them that that's just human nature and I
don't think that you're gonna change
that and I don't think that we're going
to win people to do more of this if
we're just telling them that they're
negligent parents they are negligent
parents when their kids have been
training throughout high school and now
and entering college and they were like
don't worry we'll keep our heads down
let me explain when when Benjamin
Franklin said those who would give up
their freedoms for temporary security
deserve neither and will lose both that
doesn't just apply to the government it
exists in every facet these people who
think I'll keep my head down and scrape
by you are sacrificing your principles
you are sacrificing the future for your
children now when it comes now you think
hold on you think I'm gonna I'm gonna
allocate resources in defense of people
who knew this was going on it's been
going on for a decade and they are now
saying oh no now my kids are losing
races sorry Leah Thomas has abided by
all of the rules undergoing a year of
hormone treatment so that she could
qualify for this and where were the
parents to come out and say no to this
oh I'm sorry you're saying the parents
weren't paying attention to the rules
that they were putting I'm not saying
I'm saying that could be option a option
b could just be the they think this too
shall pass I think that there is an
element of people especially over the
age of like 40 45 in this country
they're like it didn't used to be this
way this this ain't gonna be a thing
this will go away and that now they're
waking up and realizing oh this ain't
going away and we need to do something
so so I respect the letter absolutely
100 the parents who are coming out now
now being like this is wrong yeah
they're scared and I wish the female
athletes would speak up if I I would
totally wish they would but I get that
everyone's cost benefit analysis is
different and if these girls go on and
start a gaming company and are actually
legitimate successful real feminist
business owners that don't discriminate
against people and have intellectual
like like diversity at their companies
amazing they have to like think about
the ends here before they say something
and I don't and this is why they want to
undermine people this is why the the the
moderates independence the libertarian
types are losing culturally or at least
have been for some time because the left
is willing to go scorched Earth they'll
literally send shock troops with
crowbars and Molotov cocktails to get
what they want they will put their names
on giant signs and say this is who I am
and I refuse when they go to work uh
there was one person who went to Taco
Bell working there and wore a black
lives matter mask and the boss said you
can't wear that it's political and they
said I'm wearing it or I'm I'm quitting
and they said you're fired I said fine
took a picture posted online the entire
left rallied around him got his job back
and forced the company to bend its knee
the right just says but if but you know
but I got to think about feeding my kids
in the future so I'm not going to engage
in this and they lose lose I I agree
with most of that I just think that you
have to be understanding of the people
that have to feed their kids and don't
want to lose their future and so we need
to be more organized we need to be
better at a narrative and we need to be
understanding that emotional
um stories and emotional examples can
can kind of engage people and get them
in and then you can fill them with facts
and encourage them to speak up well sure
sure but where was this attitude that
I've heard of consistently over the past
few years of if I speak up I could lose
my job and how do I feed my kids and I'm
like have you looked at the cost of
cereal it's going up 20 have you look at
the the wholesale inflations up nearly
10 the fastest on record Consumer Price
uh in increases are up at a 40-year high
inflation is about to run away they've
they've printed what 30 to 40 percent of
all U.S dollars in the past year and a
half and people keep saying but I got to
make sure there's food for my kids yo if
you keep complying with this you're not
going to have anything for your kids and
I'm saying this is where you and the
Joe's and the bends and the and the
rogans of the world can give these
people then the talking points and the
encouragement that they need to actually
say something because I think especially
for women we totally like second guess
ourselves and we are like did that
happen did that oh I don't know did the
teacher really say that like did that
kid really say that to my kid and like
should I say something well I don't know
I don't want to lose a friend and all
this stuff and we are like in the moment
of just life that we are think that we
don't have the voice and are afraid that
we don't have I get told this all the
time by people specifically women that
are like I feel like I can't say what
you say because I won't sound as good
saying it I'm like I don't even say it
that good I don't know what y'all are
talking about but I think that that
people like us have to use our voices
and give these people the talking points
and the help that they need to go
scorched Earth and to show it to the
companies that we're not going to put up
with this anymore I agree with that the
challenge is if the
lowest tier of antifa on the leftists
random people on the internet are
willing to plaster their names their
sacred honor and their families behind
their principles and the and the other
side the independent libertarian types
are not willing to do that then it's
clear which side is going to dominate
the culture War yeah but are they really
I see lots of like empty Twitter faces
and profiles that that tweet major
companies you know trying to get into a
stop like and they wear masks and they
have strategy yeah but these are people
who are willing to go out on January
20th 2017 and and burn and torch
vehicles and smash windows and when they
got arrested institutional powers that
they've organized got them all released
except for those who pled guilty
ignorantly and then you look at what
happens with you know as a right-wing
group concept can walk outside for a
March holding up signs saying peace and
love and they'll say it's a far-right
Nazi rally
so the these people have ceded that
power to the establishment media they're
not working in these in these industries
and look
if you're not willing to engage and I I
will point this out too obviously the
left has The High Ground because
absolutely yeah and that's why we have
to be smart and absolutely absolutely
they don't just have the media though
they have all of the other Industries in
which I mentioned that scared women
message me every day right stem
education fashion but Finance so so
while I recognize there are some you
know strategic limits yep what do you
think would have happened if as soon as
this race so so this Leah Thomas won the
race by over 38 seconds compared to the
next fastest rifle like when I was
watching a video of this I saw people
swimming the wrong way and I was
confused because I've watched swimming
before I've watched like you know
Olympic races oh didn't they all dive
off the same and then they go back and
they go back and they go back and I'm
like why is this person going back oh
they're just outlapping the other people
that whoa yep what do you think would
have happened if all of the women who
were there refused to race
oh it they probably would have been
kicked out of school that's my
assumption you think that the schools
would have been like I think I didn't
get picked out I think no I think they
would have been like there's no race I
think that that's well there's no race
but then all the sjws and all of the
woke people on Twitter and all of the
corporations that maybe sponsor the team
and uh any of the coaches or the medical
staff or you know the groups on campus
the lgbtq groups would have outed those
girls and made their lives miserable and
if they weren't kicked out by the
administration they would have been
scared to ever set foot on that campus
that's what would have happened they
deserve to lose absolutely well if if
you if you are unwilling to sacrifice
and take personal responsibility for
your future and for what you believe in
then you don't deserve it and and I hope
that I'm raising my girls our motto
every day is to be strong sweet and
smart that they have the independence
and the forethought and this inner
strength to do what is right but I think
that ostracizing people by belittling
the small steps that they're willing to
take and saying well you're not risking
enough is not going to win more people
to our side either they're unwilling to
stand up for what they believe in
this letter for them is like what
they're willing the parents aren't the
adult Ian made a good point these people
are competing are adults they're
responsible for themselves if you're
look you but you know Money Talks so if
the parents are the ones paying 80 grand
a year really the parents saying
something maybe makes more of a
difference than the girl saying I'm not
going to swim there are so many people
you know when you were mentioning it's
like you know you said me Joe Ben and
people who speak up and bring these
things up if you were gonna sit back and
say someone else will do it for me I
guarantee you you will lose oh
absolutely and that's that's literally
how what I spend every day is like I am
here to speak for a lot of people but
like we need more of us and we need more
average people and there is strength in
numbers so it's hard for me to be up
look so my personal opinion is there
should be a a women's feet you know
female Division and then there's a male
Division and maybe we do a trans
division where you know it can be mixed
but right now if the rules were changed
but by the way sorry sidebar if if
you're a woman that is transitioning to
a man you're still not going to be the
man that's transitioning to a woman so
there shouldn't be a Transit have we
there's no way I was just thinking the
same thing there's no way biologically
there's no way that's that's not that's
not true I think really are you familiar
with Mac bags no this is the the
biological female who started
transitioning to become male
testosterone ends up with broad
shoulders muscle mass and all that stuff
when you comp I think there's there's
obviously going to be some research into
this but it is true that biological
males who undergo hormone therapy do
have reduced muscle mass and stamina
endurance Etc and then females who
undergo of course therapy gain it so
there might be you know immediate I
don't think so I think genetically and
naturally there are so many scientific
differences that are just in our bodies
as men and women in in those like two
Sexes that it there there can't be I
don't think there could be
regardless and that's huge and that's
true but we have height division
cellulite muscles like your body like
your bones everything and if we create a
new division that people can choose to
enter then they're free to choose to
enter it or not I'm I'm okay with that
sure yeah so if it's a pub if it is a
public school I think unfortunately this
is going to start coming over to much
like they did with the gay marriage
thing and sex education and CRT it's
gonna start inkling its way if it hasn't
already and I think in some places it
has into religious schools as well I
want to give a shout out to Clifton
Duncan who tweeted something I think is
really great he said my contempt for
covidians has been surpassed by my
contempt for people who know something
is wrong and stay silent and I was like
yep
but uh you know what ends up happening
is when people are unwilling and outside
of the issue of these schools we'll move
on from that when people are unwilling
to stand up for any of these issues what
you end up with with you end up with
Hyper individualism people basically
saying if no one else is willing to
rally and defend this I'm on my own I'm
gonna stay on my own well and but that
can be so once again like
going back to Hell women are so
different than men that anxiety and that
isolation can be so paralyzing and and I
think that it all all it takes is mine I
would just tell anybody like just find a
person that agrees with you on something
you don't have to clearly you and I
don't agree on on everything but I hope
we walk away friends after this and
we're gonna like fight the cause
together after this right because we
agree on the majority of things that
need to be done to make the country a
better place and to keep it at the
greatest nation in the world and so I
think that people you're right they
become
um lackadaisical and they become lazy
and they become isolationists in a sense
because they think that they are all
alone in their thinking and they don't
see anyone else speaking up and so I
just want to encourage more parents and
more swimmers and more everybody to
speak up in any way that you possibly
can because then more of those voices
make a difference like look at all those
incredible parents that were like I'm
gonna go to my local school board
meeting yep and that made an impact and
they're winning yeah and we need more of
them so I got a good example we got this
story from Business Insider anti-vaxxers
storm a New York Cheesecake Factory in
protest that ends in six arrests that's
the story anti-vaxxer is a funny term
these are basically Andy mandate
protests so that's me they showed up to
the Cheesecake Factory they they're like
they were apparently refused to be
seated so they decided to seat
themselves as my understanding and then
the manager was like you can't be in
here the police showed up they said
we're not going to leave they were
chanting things like that are they
anti-vaxx for the first shot the second
shot the the third shot or the fourth
shot because there are actually yeah
there are a lot of people who did who
did take the shot that that don't want
it to be mandated on people and they're
still being called anti-vaxxers when
they took the shot themselves I think
they were four the first not the second
not the third but the fourth it totally
makes sense but these are but these are
people putting skin on the line these
are people coming into a restaurant
peacefully saying hey we want some
service here the restaurant comes up to
them says hey we have to comply with
this role and this role and this role in
this world with the federal government
and they said you know what no no no no
no no no no we're not going to comply
with the government whims that you
demand of us and then they're like okay
we're going to call the police they call
the police the police carried out these
orders and these decrees by of course
but hold on bureaucrats and they
arrested these people I think there's
some there's an interesting you know
sort of Middle Ground here watching
these videos it was very reminiscent of
watching leftist protest as well the
protesters did not understand what they
were what was going on they were saying
you can't kick us out to public
accommodation we're allowed to be here
and it's like bro you you can be told to
leave the police aren't there because of
the vax mandates they're there because
you're trespassing exactly a private
business has a right to exclude you from
business but that's not the argument
that a lot of people on the left make
you have to bake the cake you do have to
provide a service no matter what so
these people are using the same
arguments and a lot of people are
bringing in parallels to this to what
happened in the 1960s with some of the
restaurant sit-ins that happened then
that was fighting against discrimination
and there is a lot of discrimination a
lot of segregation that deserves to be
pushed back that violates human rights
that's being called on by bureaucrats by
big statists who are violating the most
sacred right of all the right to exist
the right to be able to buy food and
water and that's incredulous and crazy
so yeah that that's where I go to real
quick like I thought that food was an
essential service now maybe you could
argue oh well you're not you don't have
a right to go to Cheesecake Factory or
Delmonico Steakhouse or McDonald's but
it's not just that it's also
supermarkets but but well but in all of
the mandates that I've seen there is a
carve out for grocery stores because I
think that they knew that they would get
not in some places not in some places
like in Canada where they give the right
for supermarkets and in Australia and in
Minnesota Australia is a yeah so many
friends that are so many friends that
are Aussies and that's insane I think
the thing that you mentioned about like
bodily autonomy and like your individual
health care rights it's kind of funny
how the left used to say like healthcare
was a human right and like your body
your choice until now
um I get really annoyed by the people
that try to make the comparison to the
Hobby Lobby case because I tweeted
earlier tonight that um you know your
your employer should not be able to tell
you like what to put in your body or
what to do with your body especially if
it's not a detriment to your job
performance or the safety of those
around you and people were like oh yeah
but what about Hobby Lobby and I'm like
Hobby Lobby didn't tell their employees
no you can't take Contra contraceptives
they said we are morally opposed to
paying for that yeah and and then I've
also had people because like I said I'm
a home birth hippie they're like well
your employer knew you were having a
home birth I'm like the only reason that
Jeremy boring knew I was having a home
birth is because I talk about it all the
time and I try to convince people to do
the same thing and I love being a doula
I'm like but my employer your employer
doesn't know your birth plan your
employer doesn't know what vaccines
you're going to give your kids your
employer doesn't know any of that stuff
your insurance company that your
employer subsidizes does but not the
employers and now you have like Kroger
grocery stores which they own Ralphs in
in California and I legitimately I'm
like I spend thousands of dollars a
month at Ralph's I will find a different
grocery store just for the audience they
just announced that they're going to be
cutting away benefits for their unvaxed
workers and employees that's the major
decision they're also trying to get into
the Florida market and a lot of Florida
up people are saying hey don't support
this business and this is the way to do
it so vote with your dollar support the
businesses that that's you that support
you that support your individual liberty
your individual freedom but in New York
City a lot of these businesses are told
to obey and go along with the edicts
today five-year-olds have to show their
vax mandate paperwork and their
identification when it comes to indoor
uh stores and businesses
the people who comply the stores and
businesses yes absolutely I so wish
um there's a lot of places that are not
complying in LA and I don't want to
publicize who they are because I don't
want the health department to come and
knocking but I've heard from a lot of
businesses there and I'm sure it's it's
the same in other places it's like we're
not going to comply it kind of depends
on the enforcement of it right that's
the bottom line because in La I think
for the LA County Health Department for
restaurants that don't require vax cards
and bars and stuff like that the first
fine is a thousand dollars most people
can scrounge up that money right the
second find is like two the third one is
ten and after that you can lose like all
of your licenses and it's and that is a
lot for a business who maybe still be in
the red from the government shutting
them down during covid to say am I
willing to take this risk but they're
willing to take the risk of violating
the Ada in the EEOC
they're unaware though this goes back to
no they're not I've got people that are
out I called a couple dozen New York
restaurants and they were just like yep
like every every one of these businesses
has to have that thing on the wall that
explains you can't discriminate in the
basis of medical conditions yeah so I
called these restaurants and one of them
I asked I was like I talked to 26 and I
said would you discriminate against
someone in the basically medical
conditions they all said yes one of them
I was like so you know my question he
was like which do you think is worse
like the thousand dollar fine for
violating the executive order or the
potential 250 000 fine for human rights
violations under New York city and state
law and they hung up on me yeah because
they probably probably do not know and
they're like the thing is on the wall
and they don't understand they're like
this guy this guy's pranking me I think
it's weird that they would know about a
decree like an executive order like
verbatim but they wouldn't know about
their own business really when the media
is like pushing it and touting it and
talking about how important it is the
mayor and the governor and the president
of the United like all speakers yes
because the people who run these
businesses have to file to get these
things and are sent to them and they
hang them up so like if they have you
ever met somebody that like Works in HR
that hangs that up they're not passing
it off businesses in New York City are
not big corporate collaborates they're
small restaurants it's like it's mostly
small businesses actually the majority
of restaurants in the country are are
owned by immigrants women and and in New
York City High small businesses I'm
calling and talking to the managers and
the owners yeah and they know this they
know they're violating the violating the
Americans then they've dug their grave
right right so so I'd love to say and
they've lost what is it like 63 There
isn't there's an article even before
this second like mandate here's what we
need we need a a president who is going
to tell this country all of these
businesses will be investigated for
violations of the Equal Employment you
know law equal employment laws the
Americans with Disabilities Act because
in New York City they actually are
firing people who have like
Guillain-Barre syndrome this is this was
the craziest thing to me when they
announced that the vaccine mandate meant
that if you were medically barred from
getting the vaccine against people no I
want to see them find I want to see them
find the maximum penalty for that yeah I
also think that if you're a guy that or
a gal that owns a business that's going
to do that to your employee at a small
business my mom owns and operates a
small business and has for years and
there's a lot of incredible small
business owners out there that care
about their people like you're probably
an [ __ ] boss before coven if you're
willing to fire somebody during covid
for not getting the job there's a lot of
businesses exactly like and that's
another extreme of like you're a jerk we
also have to understand there's a lot of
businesses that are not complying that
are they're not going along with this
one because they can't afford to they
can't afford extra staff there's already
a staffing shortage and and now they're
going to have to discriminate against
people who will or will not be able to
enter their business to transact
financially with them that's absolutely
crazy this these regulations these
mandates hurt and butcher small
businesses but they allow Mega National
corporations to succeed because they
could hire the extra person they could
have the security guard outside and of
course they don't face the full brunt of
the state but again a lot of people in
New York City not complying a lot of
people in Manhattan complying Brooklyn
not so much and that's why it's it's
also crazy to see major Hospital unions
also a lot of major institutions like
Amtrak just totally dropped the vaccine
mandate because they they can't go along
with it because they can't hire enough
people to do the jobs that they need to
get done they were gonna have to shut
down train Services delay and they're
like we literally can't so the vaccine
mandates out yeah well Amtrak just
announced that a couple of months ago by
the way that they're not going to go
along with it you know there's a there's
like legal defense funds and stuff that
I follow to on on social and you are
seeing like small wins you're seeing the
delays and it all it needs to do is
start with the delay and then hopefully
one day it'll go away completely well
there's three judges that are going
against Biden's mandate but the Biden
Administration has plans on the table to
set up a domestic passport system when
it comes to Interstate travel where
they're going to be checking vaccine
passports that's some of the plans that
they want to put forward
but this is something that has already
been implemented in Australia yeah
absolutely Commerce Clause anyone
Australia Australia is a bunch like the
people of Australia are some of the not
all of them yeah but they're very very
cowardly they're the most compliant
people I've ever met in my entire life
and they're like oh it's okay we'll see
okay like if I do this then they'll
leave me alone if I do this then they'll
leave me alone the United States is like
the Trope of the Armed redneck in a tank
being like
preemptive attack
like the I love that Family Guy joke
where um Kermit the Frog is playing he's
like playing the banjo or whatever and
someone's they're going through a swamp
and they're like hey can you tell me
where town is and then he pulls out a
shotgun yeah it's back the way you came
that's that's the trout man don't don't
screw around with people like get off my
property dude my husband likes so
Winter's Bone I love Jennifer Lawrence
like the one that she's not made for an
Oscar for their my husband always tells
people it's like you know where Alicia's
from they're like no I'm like well
here's Oklahoma and there's where I'm
from and then my husband's like have you
seen Winter's Bone and they're like yes
and he's like that's where Elisha is
from nice people look look Australia's
Got You know their crazy spiders and you
know kangaroos you see that video where
the kangaroo is like banging on the
glasses they used to have rats that were
like climbing into cribs and trying to
eat babies so it's a scary place but for
whatever reason the government comes out
and they're like we're gonna lock all
you in camps and they're like that's all
right mate so the reason why is it
actually is a society that is very like
middle class upper middle class like
everybody is middle class like if you
are if you drive an airport shuttle
there you're like middle class and I
have a lot of friends that are
Australian and love them dearly and one
of my girlfriends just became an
American citizen by the way it's super
cool
um she has like family still over there
especially her grandparents and they've
talked about like this upper class much
like in the United States right like you
have these rich elitists that can still
go to Mexico and fly their private
planes and send their kids to the 70
grand a year you know private school in
L.A and pretend like everything's okay
Chrissy Teigen but but
um it is the lower class there it is
like the blue collar people that are the
ones that are going out and protesting
and and getting their you know what's
handed to them by the cops really brutal
stuff that is disgusting that is not
being covered by media anywhere and it's
kind of like the upper class it's like
oh you know we we got the shot we're
okay and it is the it is the the the
poor The underrepresented Underdogs
there that are like no enough is enough
and I'm like good for them like if any
of you are watching good for you like
God bless you it's the poor people that
have been predominantly the victims here
they're the ones that are losing their
money losing their savings losing their
economic uh Mobility losing any kind of
economic uh opportunities they're the
ones absolutely getting riddled with
regulations restrictions they can't
operate a small business multinational
corporations they could be open when
lockdowns are imposed on everyone else
they could conduct business they of
course could afford the regulations they
could afford the extra taxes they could
afford every little whim of that the
government puts on them because they're
working hand in hand together and
working out secret deals that
essentially benefit them and that's why
we're seeing the largest transfer of
wealth and recorded human history
happening right now let's talk about
what's going on in New York City New
York City passes green gas ban experts
warn could lead to electrical blackouts
and soaring bills de Blasio backed law
will Outlaw gas stoves and heaters in
all new building properties so that is
January 2024 all new buildings and
taller ones what is it shorter buildings
of seven stories have to go electric by
January 2024. you know New York City is
it's like it's going to be have you seen
Escape From New York yeah that's what
it's going to be like and and that's a I
love that movie it's hilarious when you
like he crash have you seen you've seen
it right Ian yeah yeah a month a couple
months ago we put it on the lighter
upstairs yeah and he lands on the
rooftop going down the building
everything's yes hot old guy list
everything's destroyed Bill de Blasio
said he wants to buy up these buildings
that are you know collapsing in value
becoming vacant to use as public housing
oh I gotta say it looks like everything
he's doing it has the rebuilding the
projects and segregating people
destroying property value forcing people
to flee because he's Conquering the city
now Banning Banning the gas in buildings
well there you go I mean it's look their
vision of a future someone someone had a
really really great tweet they said
the elites that they were referring to
space travel but I think it applies to
all of them they were like the the
elites do not want Star Trek like they
do not want a Star Trek feature they
want a future more like Dune they want
classist elitist control of everything
that they can annihilate you know
exactly this cooking over an open flame
is probably more than a magnitude better
than cooking on an electric wire stove
where you can't get when you have a
flame you can pick the pot up and move
it around and tilt it to get the heat
exactly right where you need it for the
food Ian knows from experience the
quality of food is going to drop in New
York can you I just imagine like all the
chefs in the world that are like right
you need Open Flame to look what are
they gonna do
um they're gonna have torches and
they're gonna be holding the pan with a
torch under it they'll come up with a
really cool like hipster thing where
there's a grill in the restaurant yeah
my my concern is not so much about the
quality of of the food they cook but um
the blackout the rolling blackout it
literally killed people yeah especially
Mark remember remember that freak ice
storm that was horrific like earlier
this year that killed people in Texas
partly because they were trying to do
this clean energy move that wasn't a
good thing and oh you know the windmills
froze after they killed all the birds
and used more natural gas to make them
than it actually put outputs New York is
freaking miserable do you and and this
is this is a problem do you think that
Greta tunberg knows that her plan would
kill millions of people in a matter of
weeks no when she's like how dare you
she said like we must we must wait until
2030 or 2023 we must do it now it's like
if you shut off fossil fuels right now
you'd probably kill 10 million people in
a weekend usually because all the
electricity goes out people who who are
diabetic oh they die instantly because
their insulin goes bad and then within
the matter of a couple weeks the elderly
start dying from a lack of access to
Heating and Cooling yep so is you know I
have to I have to give her the benefit
out and soon she just doesn't realize
she's talking about genocide no she's
being fed talking points by the evil
environmentalist lobby of the world
there's another discrepancy though you
talk about how poor people
underprivileged people have been so
negatively hurt by covet and regulations
um here's something that people leftists
and radicals don't want to talk about
um is is the the poverty index when it
comes to energy and the energy poor in
the world and the best way to raise
their future their educational their
medical like their professional economic
growth is to provide these people with
the energy that now Bill de Blasio and
Gavin Newsom are trying to take away and
private entities are the best way to do
this like if you want to have a cleaner
Planet let corporations do what they do
like the private Market has been so much
better for creating clean initiatives
than the government regulation or
bureaucrats or you know tax bonuses have
ever been I went to Iceland a couple
years ago and it's beautiful it's
amazing it's expensive a little bit and
what I was told by locals there was that
I was like how is it that people live up
here you know what I mean it's like it's
you know it's it's it's day out until
midnight or whatever survival yeah
there's like where do you get food from
like how do you grow food everything
smells like farts yeah and it's true
they have greenhouses natural gas they
have greenhouses for growing vegetables
and then what I was told was before the
the um Advent of geothermal they were
some of the poorest people in the world
working in like mines just covered in
filth and struggling to survive yeah but
once they got access to cheap clean
energy their their standard of living
skyrocketed yep now it works for them
because they live on a gigantic you know
volcanic hot spot but for people who are
in the middle of you know America you
know we gotta ship in oil and gas to
them so they have the ability to have
the energy they can use for farming
equipment they shouldn't have to when
we're sitting on some but because I mean
I mean I mean areas I don't have access
to it right like certain not every area
has you know sitting on oil yeah and so
we have pipelines yep so we can ship it
to them so we can say there's a lot here
there's a little here let's move it
around and this gives people better
quality of life now I'm concerned about
you know climate change and all that
stuff too so I'd love me some fusion
there was a there's a new report I'm
really excited about they finally got
energy output from Fusion you see that
Ian yeah but it might have been debunked
oh really
why you got it I'm just a fan of like
nuclear energy yes like everybody
assumes that Chernobyl is gonna happen
and I'm like guys no if you watch the
HBO documentary yeah and then you
actually read a history book you will
see that like Chernobyl ain't gonna
happen and even with the uh the Japanese
plant that that had all the issues yeah
what was it Fukushima Fukushima yeah
okay as I say properly oh well
properly much much like you can't say my
name is
if these people though really cared
about forward movement
it was Energy race to be clean then they
would be looking into nuclear infusion
why don't they because look people don't
understand the problem with Chernobyl
was not nuclear power it was communism
exactly a thousand percent that was like
the most conservative pro-capitalistic
like American agenda show I have ever
seen come out of Hollywood when my
husband I watched that show I was like
did they realize what they were it's
like squid games right like the writer
thinks that it's like a thing about how
evil capitalism is this one really got
me to because I said that several times
that squid game was very clearly about
communism yes and all the leftists were
like tips so dumb he doesn't understand
capitalism and I said if it was if it
was an allusion to capitalism when they
did the red light green light some
people would have started at the Finish
Line some people would have been in the
middle and some people have been in the
back yeah when everyone was put in a
jumpsuit and put at the beginning and
told equalizer run for it yeah that's
communism not capitalism yep a thousand
percent I I do kind of love it though
when Hollywood assumes that there's even
some some things that they've come out
with recently that I watch it and I'm
like so I'm like this is pro-life like
how did somebody how did somebody like I
am mother did you watch I am mother
um it's a pretty good like sci-fi movie
on on Netflix and like I've watched it
I'm like it's told I don't want to give
it away but it's like totally love on
the Spectrum I totally almost cry every
episode love on the Spectrum it's like
about people on the spectrum that are
trying to find love and like marriage
and happiness and I'm like this show is
so pro-life because I do anyway have you
seen the order no so this still got
canceled there's only two seasons but so
I'll just spoil it because it's it you
know I think it's it's it's this came
out like a year ago the villain in the
second season this is this is like um
it's a college age show so it's
targeting people who are in their like
18 to 24. the villain in the second
season is an overt Communists it's an
over it's over Communists uh they go to
this guy's this professor's house and
he's got they look at his books it's
like Stalin marks and the show is about
a secret society of you know man had
people of magic and that you know in
order to cast a spell you have to
sacrifice something so they cut their
hands as a sacrifice to like Casa spell
and the Communists believe that there is
an incantation that will give everyone
the ability to freely use magic and the
leader of the order is like if it were
true don't you think it would have
happened by now people have tried this
over and over again you either pay now
or you pay later and I'm like man Pro
capitalist Netflix show literally like
it's one thing if the villain was like
not overtly reading books on Marx yeah
and they just said I believe in equality
for magic but they're literally alike
their group was called Praxis and
they're like Marx it's good and they
were like Workers Unite and I'm like man
they just slapped Us in the face with
this one I I off I would love to think
I'd not heard about that show but I
would love to think that somewhere in
Hollywood is like a pro-capitalist like
conservative that did that on purpose I
flipped it in it got canceled though I
wonder if if at Netflix they were just
like look a lot of our show shows follow
themes that are more pro-leftist yeah
maybe if we make a show that follows
another theme we might actually see like
maybe people like this stuff and they
made the show and you know not enough
people watched it it sounds a little too
like satanic for me I don't typically
like those kinds of shows yeah like it's
it's not a great show
[Laughter]
they said a pro capitalistic message up
for failure is what you're saying I
gotta I gotta be honest like I I was eye
rolling at the overt politics that they
had injected into it and I was like and
I don't want that in my entertainment I
just want to be entertained I wanted the
werewolf to fight the wizard yeah I mean
and and like it's a brutal show because
like they show people getting their
hearts ripped out and stuff like that
well most entertainment now is
propaganda and and it's and it's hard
not to see it shows that are propagated
horrible yeah it's awesome Ally Stucky
the other day had a thing where she was
like posting on her stories her insta
stories all of the things that are kind
of just like just subtly in kids shows
and there's a show that my
eight-year-old likes to watch and I
walked in and I was like what and I
could show you a video I took a video of
it and I showed it to my husband and
it's like a man in a sequence jacket
with an effeminate voice and like a ton
more makeup on than I'm wearing right
now and fabulous fake eyelashes and
painted nails and I was like hey to my
eight-year-old I'm like who's this guy
she's like oh he's just on this episode
He's the bad guy and he like wants to
take over social media it was like a
very like 2021 like Trend right and she
was like that's the bad guy don't worry
Henry Danger is going to get him
whatever the show it was and I was just
like oh my gosh it's happening or you
even like like the bad guy was
effeminate yeah but I'm like well at
least they'd acknowledge that you know
we I love it when there's bad ladies on
shows I'm like you know women can be
evil too like Kim jong-un's sister
anyone um but so it's it's have you seen
the boys no but I've heard it's really
good the uh and I I think it's a second
season I don't know whatever I I haven't
seen it in a minute but one of the
characters is literally meant to be I'm
pretty sure like I think they were
trying to rip off Laura Loomer really so
they got this this she's like a Nazi
like superhero or whatever and I think
it was a leftists version of the worst
like they look at Laura Loomer like for
real watch watch it and you know Laura
if you end up seeing this I wonder if
she's seen it because when I saw that
they announced before the season that
they were introducing an alt-right
superhero or something like this and I
rolled my eyes like you know like
they're trying so hard so original and
all oh I remember back got Ann Coulter
like I feel like there's so many
characters I think it was like Ally
McBeal SVU like all these even movies
where they would show like the you know
kind of like CNN type new set that's
commenting on what's ever happening in
the movie right like I think even a day
after tomorrow there was very much
there's always like the blonde that's
making that argument and they would make
her be attractive and thin and tall like
Ann Coulter and it's like it's visually
that's what you know that that's what
they were thinking in the writer's room
I want to make sure I make this point
clear too I am not saying that Laura's a
Nazi I'm saying you have these leftists
in Hollywood who get this fake media
view of what Laura Loomer is and then
make a character based on this fake
version you know what I mean I mean I'm
surprised that they haven't done a fake
version of like Rogan or Shapiro or you
know what I mean it's it's bound to
happen probably there's a new show on
Netflix called was it was it called
conspiracy theory is that what it is um
I forgot the name of it oh yeah I want
to watch that I put it in my in my face
I watched the later episodes when it
gets filled with property but there's
there's a one of the characters is a
a psychic mushroom from Hollow Earth and
he has a bit in one episode where he
can't he doesn't want to hang out with
Joe Rogan anymore and so like they did
DMT together or something that was
fairly neutral I thought it was funny I
I just want to be entertained yeah well
you got to understand entertainment has
been weaponized you can't relax you
can't sit back you can't enjoy a lot of
content because there's a lot of
subconscious crap that they're trying to
put in your brain because when you're
watching entertainment you let your
guard down and literally your
subconscious mind picks up all these
subtle nuances all this larger messaging
all this larger propaganda and that's
why there's such big money in the
entertainment industry and that's why
there's such Sinister people like Harvey
Weinstein like Kevin Spacey within it
that do absolutely horrible things that
are able to propagandize the future of
this country and set the culture through
Hollywood there's a reason a lot of
people in Hollywood say that it's run by
Satan and and a lot of people make jokes
about it but there's a lot of parallels
there's there's there you are the lowest
of the low if you tried to sexualize my
eight-year-old like you are the lowest
of the low and if if you are trying to
and that is I think my biggest issue
with lots of lgbtq activists that you
are trying to
um change the physical emotional
hormonal and mental out like outcome of
a human being especially before they're
18 years old and and using them as a
political Pawn for your personal sexual
agenda it's not okay let's go to super
chats if you haven't already smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
we're gonna have a members only segment
coming up at timcast.com it'll be up
around 11 or so p.m so subscribe to uh
to our website as a member go to
timcast.com we have exclusive segments
that only appear on that website they'll
be on the front page let's read some
super chats we got here Darth Ribbit
says Tim the convention of States has a
Maryland chapter we have members up in
the West Virginia Maryland area we have
two Maryland senators and Reps
sponsoring the COS Bill very cool
Convention of states very very cool
awesome
all right recommorsen says Alberta is
easing restrictions on the unvaxed
because and I quote the premiere vaccine
passports are leading to mass Civil
Disobedience he's in danger of losing
his party leadership good I didn't know
that they were all a boot that up there
yeah good for you
have you ever gone up there and had
poutine no
I I know
because of my husband's dislike of it
because he's from Detroit and also Don
Cherry that's that's it it's like all I
know about Canada
all right let's see what is poutine like
is that like the basic version is just
french fries with cheese curds and gravy
but well that sounds delicious but when
you go to actual like putting
restaurants yeah they have like 30
different varieties is there like all
you can eat buffet style because I'm
from the Bible Belt and we like that it
sounds like if there's 30 different
varieties I want the thing of fries I
mean I want to be able to try the
different kinds just make it simple just
just eat a potato stop confusing things
no no Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
Biden literally went to a disaster Zone
where lives were lost and ruined and yet
folks still booed him guys it is that
bad for him yeah yeah that's a good
point I mean it's so true it's that's
yeah it's it's the effects of what
happened to pre the awful natural
disaster on top of I think people are
like screw you you're just here for a
photo op yeah for me the craziest thing
is I still can't believe that uh
tomorrow I'm going to see Spider-Man in
theaters oh yeah excited I've been just
like so so excited when the trailers
came out and I knew Toby Maguire was
going to beat it is it really like three
hours long two and a half it's
like somebody had said that they thought
it was going to be three hours long and
I'm like like why sometimes I feel like
movies it's the old lady in me I'm like
that's just 20 minutes too long I'm
excited all right let's see
Moosey Moose says DeSantis introduced a
new bill stop woke act stop wrongs
against our kids and employees act looks
like DeSantis is bringing up bringing us
Gift gifts for Christmas someone also
mentioned like stay away from DeSantis
these hours do Santa people have pointed
out that if he runs for president then
Florida lose or loses a great Governor
you know yeah but they're going to be
okay yeah I think so he can just endorse
the next guy or gal Florida man has a
reputation for a reason
I mean but don't we want to make America
Florida again we do I got our extra two
yeah Christina H says how are the rage
on behalf of the Machine songs coming
along can't wait to hear them step on
snack and find out will be awesome too
much love from my dad and I to uh to our
favorite podcast so normally we don't
announce the guests we're having in the
event that like they just cancel but uh
Michael Graves is coming right and he
was uh he was a singer of The Misfits I
believe right yeah yeah so I was
recently talking to hang out with him
it's gonna be really awesome we're gonna
set up a little Jam space and I was
telling them like we should do a big
song where we should just get as many
people who like play music to add some
some tracks to it so like you know we'll
do some like guitar here and then we've
got uh Pete perrotta formerly of The
Offspring who's doing context for us
yeah then we'll get Michael Graves to do
like some vocals Michael Knowles plays
guitar yeah um Jack busovic plays bass
Sydney Watson plays piano and sings
James O'Keefe sings right and he's a DJ
and he's a DJ and then I was like my
gosh
Ben plays the violence right and he's
not a bad he's not a bad singer so when
we did a Morning Show together we did a
a morning answer listener cruise and I
love karaoke and so we did like Kraus
karaoke one night and he sang some Frank
Sinatra to his wife who's a doctor by
the way oh and um and uh he has a good
he's pretty decent so I I said I'm here
by committing all of these people to
this song yeah on behalf of the sheep I
said it'll be called rage on behalf Rage
Against the Machine but like for real
this time yeah and or something like
that and uh because Rage Against the
Machine sold out yeah and they're now
rage on behalf of it yeah but I I do
feel like if we just do the basic tracks
and tell someone give five minutes a
throw something on top of it this is
like the freedom movements version of uh
you know a Telethon yeah it's like
instead of all we're saying is Give
Peace a chance or like one world
it's going to be a good song because
we're not going to screw around on Earth
I'm not I'm not going to stick my name
on anything back you should get like uh
John rich and Mike Rowe yeah you know
that Mike Row has like the number one
song he had like a number one song in
the country like what is he was he
playing he and well he sang it um he and
John Rich did like a dirty Santa Claus
oh my gosh Santa gets dirty like you
know songs isn't that hilarious it's
amazing yeah he's amazing yeah all right
let's see West Side Powersports says any
chance you can get Crowder on since he's
off YouTube until after the New Year
would be a great IRL also Merry
Christmas to everyone is he off I think
he got another hit he got hit yeah which
is complete BS you know and and I always
encourage people whenever they go after
Crowder YouTube gave him another strike
show your support to him with mug Club
yes but uh I I he's not taking off for
the holidays I don't think he could go
live so I think he's taking a show to
rumble for a week that's what I saw yeah
yeah yeah he's still works I I said this
earlier on Twitter I'm like when will
big Tech realize that the more you try
to silence voices it's like earned media
it's like free PR and within limits I
think it's true for bananas though um
because when they took him off YouTube
people want to watch Bannon yeah so they
just moved over to the podcasts and so
like his writing Skyrocket yeah you know
these are people who are looking for his
content the same thing is true for
Crowder Crowder's got over half a
million Subs on Rumble like so this this
was a huge mistake for YouTube yep they
only get by by forcing the Monopoly but
Crowder is not going anywhere yeah so if
he has to move to rumble his his company
still exists he still has people he's a
family to feed he has employees to to to
make sure he's doing right by them he's
not going to shut his company down
because he gets a band no and he's going
to bring those millions of people I
think it's like 30 to 40 million per
month over to rumble he has a lot of
views that's insane YouTube needs to
realize this and I will mention this too
um Nick brought this up to me I I knew
this last year I didn't realize that we
are in terms of a live show the number
one super chatted show oh hey in the
world I guess according to like YouTube
metrics and we're the 12th biggest live
show on YouTube that's awesome which is
crazy to me I didn't realize that and
they haven't tried to cancel you yet
they've they've given us a strike so I
recently so they deleted the Alex Jones
episode uh-huh right when it happened
last year and we didn't do it like I
talked to Google they said no it's done
you can't bring it back and so then I
was immediately I hit up Alex and
Michael and I was like come back we're
doing another new show because they
won't reinstate this one so I recently
decided it's been a year I'm gonna click
the appeal button and then they within a
day said we rejected your appeal and I
was like yeah yeah I know yeah the stuff
that they like try to censor to Like
Larry Elder's video on why America isn't
racist or I did a prageru video about
how America's abortion laws are more uh
left than socialist countries yeah and
they like censor it yeah Dr Dr Peter
call it was censored today yeah I
remember you saying that and it's so
crazy because it's like if you Google
what kids can watch like transgender
reading hour or a drag queen story book
hour like that's not
put with a warning that's not censored
but just factual information totally is
all right Anthony eppies Eppley says in
your discussion about virtual reality
you should look into Vasily mahanunko's
series way of the shaman Invasion and
banned from barliona they cover all the
issues you were talking about and take
it even farther in the story interesting
we're talking about um metaverse the
other day it freaks me out yeah it's
creepy man but don't you want to just uh
like here's the way I described it to uh
surrogate like the movie surrogate no no
no no no imagine this exactly you walk
over to your treadmill and you turn it
on uh-huh and then you put in your your
metaverse chip and then in your mind
you're sitting in Old Country Buffet
while your body is running on the
treadmill and then you're just eating
you know peanut butter pie brisket
you got chicken wings you got a burger
and pizza and you could eat as much as
you want and then when you're done you
take it off and you're just running on
the treadmill and you stop and get off
nope I like reality yeah you know what's
crazy some people though a lot of the
when you take drugs a lot of the
response you feel is your body's
chemical response to the drug yeah so I
wonder if you go into virtual reality
and you induce what your body thinks is
the drug that your body will produce the
response even though you didn't actually
you only took a simulated drug so
there's some insane technology that I
guess has been out for a while but now
it's like some of it is on the market
where they have like the like the
emissions of what receptors are so like
what a Jack and Coke is like and how it
makes you feel and like the body's
receptors to the I could be totally
biffing this but it's like this wearable
that you can have like a Jack and Coke
setting or a relaxed setting or uh like
a setting that makes you feel like maybe
you you know you took a hit of pot or
had some CBD and that you're not
actually ingesting it it's like this
wearable is like emitting whatever waves
do that anyway and so there is something
I think that with the metaverse like you
have those things coming together and I
think with all technology there's a an
incredible opportunity for medical
advancements and economic advancements
and educational advancements right
between like AR VR and 3D printing like
you could do medical school with people
in the middle of nowhere in like
sub-Saharan Africa that'd be incredible
um gotta get in power first which
doesn't want us to do like that but uh I
I think with that though definitely like
with great power comes great
responsibility and it's real dangerous
when you start to go the way of people
becoming
obsessed with that
falsehood right and I think it is bad
for society all right the pool of death
gaming says how do I debate people who
won't accept any news source that isn't
their preferred Source especially those
who love CNN use CNN that's why I love
using CNN so um you know CNN reported on
their producer who is you know
trafficking kids on cable TV they don't
so also I think you just got to
understand if if
you know out of 99 out of 100 articles
99 are leftist and there's one that
actually hits the nail in the head use
it and then be like what are you talking
about this is The Daily Beast like I
don't know what you want me to do New
York Times even right the New York Times
saying Joe Biden shouldn't be president
I love to post NPR stories yes it's my
fave now they falsely frame things a lot
but the point is if you're debating
someone and really trying to change
their mind you're not going to pull up
Alex Jones where he's liar turn the
freaking Frog's gay that's a little too
much for the average person but you can
pull up NPR saying something like you
know Biden's economic plans have failed
and the buildback better plan is over or
CNN reporting on his abysmal approval
rating right or how about you know it
happened only after the election but the
laptop yep you know after the election
like oh yeah this laptop actually was
real I also when it comes to covid stuff
I love to just pull straight from the
cdc's website yes people are like wait
what only you know how you know it's so
dangerous to kids you're trying to kill
your kids when you let them walk around
without a mask on Alicia and I'm like
well but how many children have died and
they're like thousands and I'm like well
actually screen grab here you go not
true exactly
all right let's see Rock Says can we
stop praising DeSantis who signs and
supports anti-free speech laws silencing
people in companies that support
boycotts of a foreign Nation I'm not a
fan of that not offended yeah
can we cycle back to what we talked
about when we were talking about MLK and
the Affairs and stuff and how nobody's
perfect yeah yeah I I would much rather
take that than you know other
Republicans who are anti-2a and do other
things too
all right let's see let's grab something
good Tyler says this is to Ian I am
sorry for the tone of previous
criticisms I have Newfound appreciation
for your contributions thank you sir
well there you go
anything else to add again moderator
Melissa is had a dream Once Joe Biden
made a made an address and said American
people it's been found our dollar value
is a Russian asset so we will use the
full power of the federal government to
put a stop to it that might be happening
right now with the moves that they've
been making I'm sorry that those are
your dreams man like dreams are supposed
to be good happy things yeah that was
like uh one of those news articles those
are interesting and creative those are
cool dreams I think the US dollar is a
Russian asset it's hilarious
Busy Bee says the parents or athletes
would have never complained if the trans
athlete would have been not good they
would have been cool with it everyone
should have stood up from the beginning
is the trans athlete allowed to use the
women's locker room
I believe so yeah I think so yeah I
wouldn't imagine why not hmm yeah I I
would have spoken up way sooner than
that yes
all right let's see there was one I saw
before
the great treasure says great guest if
you will not fight when you are most
likely to win you will fight when it is
most certain you will lose because it is
better to die than to live as a slave
Churchill you're absolutely interesting
love me some Churchill yeah he also
liked whiskey and Scar so that's cool
too that's great and freedom yes
M uh MZ Kim says there's a huge
difference between getting sued for
violating EEOC by a private individual
and the full force and effect of the
state enforcing mandates not true wrong
really though yes the EEOC comes at you
as a state agency not as an individual
I've filed National Labor Board
complaints against organizations and it
is not me personally hiring a lawyer and
going after them they get a call from
the government who says don't lie to us
here's what's going to happen next and
they go you you okay okay when you file
an EEOC complaint the government comes
after them not an individual interesting
so it's actually
um I would actually argue
when you violate the Mandate you're
going up against one man Bill de Blasio
and his executive order and then his
underlings yeah when you go when you go
when you violate someone's uh like if
someone's got a medical condition and
they can't get uh you know so you fire
them now you've got city state and
federal agencies you're going up against
so the I think it's it's clear as day
that people fear de Blasio more than
three different agencies New York City
is the Human Rights Commission the
states has Human Rights Commission and
the federal government has the EOC but
when you have uh Kathy hokel at the
state saying that God wants you to get
vaccinated and
um enforcing all these Mass mandates and
vaccine mandates and stuff like as a
business owner don't you assume that
you're really not going up against the
three you're going up again it's like
you're damned if you do and you're
damned if you don't like it's two and
two at this point and then when you have
the Biden like you really are odd man
out
rocking a hard place
all right let's see pitsu says NYC will
be the U.S gulag
perhaps I don't put the entirety of the
city
are they going to build camps like in
Australia the metaverse is the U.S Gulag
they have nowhere to put camps I mean
they're getting rid of their prisons
well he said they can't even run their
prisons de Blasio was gonna well they're
gonna release all the prisoners input
but he was saying that uh de Blasio
wants to take all the buildings like the
vacant buildings
some of these cheaper buildings in
convert them into public housing AKA
coveted prisons yep yep I could see it
well there you go
all right Stephen White says that's why
you need to come to Tennessee we have
nuclear with with the Y-12 power plant
and the hydroelection with plenty of
hydroelectric with plenty of dams I do
like Billy that's the governor there
right I don't know Billy is the governor
there Tennessee governor I'm a fan
Dawson Jackal says remember the movie
Soylent Green was set in 2022 and in New
York you will be happy
I have not seen that one maybe Bill Lee
yeah it's also important to know anyone
comes into New York City is tracked and
databased because they have toll roads I
literally take a picture of everyone
coming in yeah it's tracking your Easy
Pass that's for sure so they might
convert to a prison very easily Micah
young says there is a Ben Shapiro
character in The Daniel Craig movie
knives out it was pretty bad what was
there oh so Ben speculated that uh
what's Chris Evans character was like
supposed to be him really Chris Evans
right was it wasn't that who it was no
Chris Evans is like six foot tall and
ripped that's Captain America right yeah
but he was a nice out he's like the rich
can someone CGI Ben Shapiro has Captain
America like fighting the Winter Soldier
so you know that the guy before though
before he became Captain America I think
that's more likely no be real let's be
honest let's be honest what is everybody
you worked with him I know I'm not I'm
not making fun for his eyes I'm making
fun of the the idea that someone would
claim Chris I think it was the character
it was like the actual like demeanor and
personality and like what he said about
wealth and like education and stuff like
that I think that that's what they're
trying to do I watched a movie and I
actually really enjoyed the movie and I
didn't see the comparison no not it
can't be Chris Ben Shapiro is not a a
like the Chris Chris Evans character is
a narcissist and I don't believe Ben
Shapiro is a narcissist he's a thousand
percent not right so the Chris Evans
character was like
but if you're a radical leftist right
you watch Ben Shapiro and think that
he's a narcissist Persona of Ben Shapiro
it was crazy watching Ben debate that
dude um Malcolm Nance
and I'm like why would anyone support
Nance who is just being mean and snipe
he just literally had zero comebacks he
just looked like a like a
we got to teach America how to lose
again Ben shouldn't have said I sleep on
piles of money though but I get it you
can't you mean Thug Life you didn't want
that moment no because you're trying to
win hearts and Minds when when Malcolm
Nance said is this what you do on your
show because it sucks yeah Ben said I'll
think about that when I sleep on piles
of money yeah it's like uh dude if
they're accusing you of being a grifter
that's not the route you should go my
response would be like Malcolm like
please we're trying to do a professional
conversation here there's no reason to
get derogatory and then he would have
been like okay well I I actually he
could have tuned yeah this is why this
many EX millions of people tune into
myself I think like um you know what I
often do on Facebook when people are
agitated I just I just respond with like
I don't understand why you're being so
mean right now and then they immediately
like de-escalate not everybody I
sometimes say Jesus loves you I don't
have to oh yeah wow good no it's like
why are you being mean I don't
understand and then they'll be like well
I'm just saying and I'll be back I I you
know I know and so if someone was on the
show and they were like man you sure do
suck at what you do I just feel like
look I'm not here to to tell you like to
insult you and be mean to you man I just
want to have a conversation yeah but we
don't have to you know I'm not trying to
I I would love to go to their job and be
like you suck at what you do all day
long but it was it was still it was
really really good I mean uh Nancy I
don't think he was like um the worst in
terms of being able to respond but he
clearly these people don't have answers
you know they're talking about you know
no especially I think specifically in
that conversation or debate or whatever
you want to call it like on the CRT
stuff like Ben was a thousand percent
right like you guys are trying to label
it something else but this is indeed
what it is and Ben is like from another
planet and has the ability to almost
photographically remember all of the
details of these things and break down
those arguments watching that debate I
was just like
Ben Shapiro's Got Talent when he was
when he was just rapid fire with the
with the wit and the answers and the
recall yeah damn super smart guy yeah
don't agree with him on some issues but
super smart dare you sir yeah you better
agree with him on everything that's my
brother from another mother all right I
gotta I gotta read this one Rob Ingram
says to touching your condo from
yesterday or was it Monday about the
death sentence for rapists and pedos why
should they live free while their
victims live with a lifelong scar I want
to make sure I feel like people aren't
understanding because we got a bunch of
super chats from people who don't
understand the reason I oppose the death
penalty is because the government kills
innocent people to put it simply like I
asked Ian how many innocent people are
you willing to kill to make sure that
those bad people also die for me the
answer is zero I am unwilling to take
the chance that the state is sanctioned
to kill innocent people because it might
kill many of the bad people Benjamin
Franklin said it is better than a
hundred guilty persons Escape than one
innocent person suffer if the bad person
is locked in a steel box and can't leave
and the threat is zero then I don't
believe we should kill them it's bad
enough the state convicts innocent
people but if if the number is one out
of a thousand out of every thousand bad
people really bad evil people who are
convicted one innocent person is locked
in a steel box I still feel that is very
very bad that we have locked innocent
person in a steel box but I will be
damned if I'm gonna be the person who
says I'd like to sign off on killing
that person next because those people
are really bad too so the way I see it
is we must neutralize the threat if
there is someone who is a violent evil
murderer and it's a degree where they're
like there is no Rehabilitation there is
no release in this person they will kill
again we lock them in a steel box and we
throw away the key that way at least at
the very least you don't have to answer
to anyone as to why you took the you
were willing to kill even one innocent
person because I believe and I am not a
a very religious person but I believe
you are that in the story of Sodom
Gomorrah that God said if there's but
one righteous person I will not destroy
the city yeah but after he found zero
righteous people people he still
destroyed the city that's exactly true
and that's why I'm saying if I can see
if I'm watching someone commit an
atrocity I will act in in self-defense
of that person with the use of lethal
Force if I see someone who has just got
on a rampage they've killed several
people and they're planning on doing
again I will absolutely apply lethal
force and defense of others so right as
a person and the state comes to me and
says I'm a representative of the state
trust me when I say this person is bad
I'll say hell no but don't you think
that part of the reason why the state I
think it is a good thing that the state
does do this in certain circumstances
because you don't want armed Vigilantes
running around having Cowboy Justice
well why would that be the case because
you have parents or families of people
when the guy's locked in a box I'm not
I'm saying if the guy's out there then I
would if if someone abuses a child to an
extreme degree and is running around and
there's a threat to someone else and
someone says oh no it's this guy and
he's done these things and we know it
definitively I've watched it with my own
eyes and we've seen videos and everyone
knows I must stop him for defense of
others it's a very different situation
to the state coming to me and saying
trust me as we execute this person I
wonder how people like Elizabeth Smart
feel about that like I would be very
curious to actually talk to victims or
Natalie holloways people seem to think
I'm saying that we shouldn't kill bad
people what I'm saying is there is no
circumstance in which I will trust the
state that the person they are holding
in front of me is the guilty person what
is the statistics on that though uh I to
me it's it's irrelevant if it was one if
there is if there was a thousand guilty
people and one innocent person among the
bunch I'm not gonna I'm not gonna sign
off on that I I just I can't I I will
not justify even one innocent person
being killed for in the name of Justice
it doesn't ring for me uh I I look at
Blackstone I look at this look like like
you mentioned the story of Saturn Gamora
yeah God made sure the righteous people
were gone if I had omnipotence and I
could know for sure what was in someone
one's heart and mind be very different
story I'll put it very simply for
everybody if there was a child abuser
and bestowed upon me was was was
omniscience for only the fleeting moment
that I could see the man in his mind
replying everything he did and
confessing to it to me I'd be like pull
the switch we cannot allow this person
to to to carry on their ideas that the
damage they've done to people but the
problem I have is with the state but
don't you think that there are people in
the state and I know some of them
who who have that who sit in the room
with those guys no you don't think that
they're terrible people okay well let's
not go there and she had attacking David
delight and they were like donors they
would have put Kyle Rittenhouse in
prison for the rest of his life Kamala
Harris kept a man on death row because
she didn't want to because they had
evidence that would have exonerated him
and she didn't want to look at it it's
not even about the callousness it's not
even about the error it's not even about
them being like we didn't realize he was
innocent it's about people like Kamala
Harris literally being like I don't care
if he is innocent kill them kill them
and I'm like dude you've got you've got
really screwed up people working in
government and they are willing to say
these are the people who are willing to
say I don't care if I kill an innocent
person so long as we execute more people
and I Kamala Harris used uh did was her
office was denying parole to people but
they wanted slave labor these people are
evil and I will I will not give them the
power to kill because they will kill the
innocent people in the chat are saying
that this is the real pro-life position
to take if you're going to have pro-life
views on abortion this is also should
translate in this so the difference
between being being pro-life and being
favored favor of the death penalty is
that someone who is on death row has
done something wrong not sure we don't
know yet you're literally addicted of a
crime if they have been found guilty by
a jury of their peers yes if there's
irrefutable evidence that they have done
what they've done yeah a child before
even breathing oxygen has done nothing
absolutely nothing nothing you're the
innocent person by default yeah and
incapable of any kind of voice if you're
upset at fauci for the beagles then you
should be anti-abortion and I wanna I
wanna I wanna point something out too I
said this earlier on another segment one
of the arguments I've often made is the
challenge I have with uh with with
anti-abortion legislation would simply
just be where the government gets to be
involved in protecting the innocent well
that I understand but the issue is if
there's a woman who's got say an ectopic
pregnancy or something to what degree do
we say the government has to be involved
that doesn't mean that there's going to
be a a you know a government agent
walking in and signing check boards you
know a checklist of well to what degrees
is the government involved when a woman
births a baby into the world they really
are unless there's like a class action
quite literally the point I'm trying to
make the point I'm trying to make is
that the left is willing to entertain
almost every single circumstance that
the government intervenes in medical
decisions even to the point where a
doctor can't give you medication or you
can't buy medication unless a doctor
signs off use medication or you can't
refuse medication so I think the
important point and this is good a a an
important point for pro-life individuals
when the left says I don't want the
government involved in my private
medical decisions then say then why why
are you in favor of prescriptions the
prescriptions are quite literally you
can go to jail if you forge one that is
the guy government telling you you are
not allowed to take medication if if I
say Donald Trump says this medication is
something I should take I should be
allowed to take it right if you if you
on the left think you should not be
allowed to pharmacists should not give
it to you and the government should
regulate that you can't have it unless
it's signed off then how is it any
different from the government being
involved in abortions yeah the
government is already involved
euthanasia you can't just go to a doctor
and say I'd like to have my life ended
the government says no now my my issue
for the most part is just there's a very
difficult line as far as I'm concerned
with that I think people should be
allowed to take the medications they
choose and they want to even if it's
recreationally I'm very libertarian I
don't like the government regulating all
this stuff because fauci doesn't know he
does not know what's right for us that
guy's been wrong too much but it's a
tough moral questions however
uh the point I was making earlier this
morning why I wanted to bring that up is
that the reality is I don't think most
people are driven by principle but many
try to be I think people just have moral
lines where they're like I don't know if
I would be okay with that and sometimes
it doesn't make sense I believe this is
more you you see a phenomenal Phenomenon
with the left where they're
substantially their principles are way
lower than their emotion and then on the
right you have emotion way lower than
their principles yeah but that still
means there are going to be people on
the right who will contradict their own
principles because there are certain
moral lines they won't cross the for the
left they'll cross many moral lines
because they're driven by emotion and I
think all sides will cross a moral line
when they become about the person and
not the principal and I think you know
you can get the staunchest anti-death
penalty person in the world have them
witness one of these crimes and they'll
be the ones have them go in and look at
all the prosecutors files then they'll
be the one saying I'll pull the lever
let me do it I'll come in yep my my
challenge is ultimately on that position
with the death penalty is State bad
you know if if the if the Lord himself
came to me and said this person did
these things then I'd be like well I
mean honestly I'd say you know you pass
judgment not me right but um if it was
for the safe safety of the community and
we knew this person had forfeited their
rights to due process and it was
definitive and that in that case I'm
like all right well I'm not I'm still
not necessarily in favor of just killing
someone if you've already subdued the
threat but I understand that you support
jail State enforced jail
yes absolutely yeah so the the issue
here is so taking someone's life away
from them but letting them have three
Square meals a day in a in a box is okay
through due process but ending their
life through due processes though yeah I
don't agree with that um and it's and
it's it's namely about like
I understand a lot of people are like
look these people are so evil they
should not be allowed to live and I'm
just like I'm not the person who thinks
I have a right to determine who has a
right to live or not if this if the
threat is subdued we contain it then we
can carry on a part of me thinks it
should be up to the victims families
um interesting because there have been
cases where you have you know
guys who murdered
teenage girls and then there's like this
incredible
forgiveness and restoration and healing
where the parents come in and they like
minister to them and then their friends
and then they you know get them on a
work release and like those kinds of I'm
not that good of a person uh if it was
my kid I'd kill you myself like I would
be like that Dad in the Larry Nasser
courtroom that jumped over the bench to
beat the you know what out of him and
and I think that a part of this is I
think it goes back to like America's
roots and like good old-fashioned well
biblical judeo-christian values and then
the good old west of like you do you
done wrong to my family and like eye for
an eye here so Rob Ingram says I get
your reasoning but you can avoid the
government executing innocent innocent
Folks by ensuring they are guilty Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt Beyond A Reasonable
Doubt also show all proof in a televised
trial but beyond A Reasonable Doubt is
the quiet is exact is exactly the
opposite of definitively true Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt just means an average
person says this is the most likely
scenario it is beyond a reasonable doubt
however there are many people who have
been convicted of crimes there was one I
was watching recently about I can't
remember who covered this a security
guard heard a gunshot called the police
the police came and found a dead young
woman they blamed the security guard and
then they prosecuted and convicted him
he went to prison for 18 years later it
turns out the state knew that there was
a gang that was robbing the neighborhood
and was there but they just wanted a
prosecution yeah so beyond A Reasonable
Doubt yes when they went to the jury and
they said he was there he was armed he
he was uh you know the only person at
the scene and they said here's exactly
why and the Jerry said well it's proven
to me Beyond A Reasonable Doubt and the
dude was innocent the whole time and it
took away his eight they took away 18
years of his life so I'm actually in
favor of this
they don't they typically don't pay
people who are convicted who are
innocent because they say we didn't do
anything wrong I don't care if the state
wants to deprive someone of life liberty
in the pursuit of happiness and it turns
out they were wrong they should be
responsible absolutely I I would agree
with that yeah
so I actually think this if someone is
arrested for a crime and they're going
to be held without bail they should be
put up in a standard like three-star
hotel room not literally a hotel but
their their detainment should be a nice
bed with turndown service a TV access to
the internet because taking away
someone's access to Communications on
the basis of presumption of a crime
without proving it I think it's wrong
well if you storm in a three-star you're
gonna get people committing crimes that
are destitute because it's better than
where they the hell hole that they live
yeah the I mean these are these are the
challenges I would I would sure find
whatever some people will keep
committing crimes to go back to jail
because they feel more at home no
because when you actually get convicted
then they bring you to the you know less
nice place my point is Kyle Rittenhouse
was was in jail for three months with no
shower and there yeah he should have
been in a normal I'm not saying give him
a luxury condo I'm saying give him a
nice bed of TV in the internet because
it turns out guess what he didn't do it
he was innocent he was he was acting in
self-defense he was found not guilty by
a jury of his peers so with that being
said why did he spend three months
locked down there are people who go to
jail as they get sentenced to three
months for their crimes Kyle Rittenhouse
spent three months in jail and he was
innocent so he should have been I agree
with that there should be a payout for
those types of people yeah I think they
should pay him out the problem is is
then when you have the Casey Anthony
type cases
where here or the O.J Simpson where
you're like uh where where do you draw
the line
I'm going to say one more thing on this
uh Matt Armstrong says ban all abortions
in the U.S it is genocide my final
thought before we go to the member
segment I believe if there is going to
be a Civil War in this country oh well
I'm sorry we're in a cold Civil War it's
an information War for sure but if it
becomes kinetic I believe abortion will
be the the moral catalyst
when when when uh here's my here's my
timeline for potentialities I'm not
saying it's possible it's true I'm just
saying the Supreme Court has already
signaled they'll overturn Roe v Wade
June 2022. at least that's what the left
is saying and that's what NBC and many
other outlets are saying then you get a
red wave in November and a bunch of
Republicans in the Senate and Congress
pass a federal abortion ban now that Roe
v Wade has been overturned but Joe Biden
vetoes it the 2024 election results in
the Republicans saying the first thing I
will do is I will sign this bill you
know the ban abortion bill then you'll
get blue State saying we will not abide
by this federal law well yeah you
already have news I'm saying that
California is going to be an abortion
sanctuary and then you're going to get
federal law enforcement by Red States
demanding it be ended because it's a
moral uh it's a moral evil but the the
as I stated Democrats on the left aren't
going to storm red states to set up
abortion clinics right but red States
National Guard law enforcement feds will
go in to shut down illegal abortion
clinics should have log it passed so
that's my potential timeline and if
those things were to pass then I believe
you could end up with states trying to
secede and things like that so that's
just my final thought on that one but we
got to go to the members only we're
gonna start recording that members only
segment so go to timcast.com and become
a member that's in the top right corner
you can sign up we're gonna have a
member segment coming up and uh make
sure to check out you get access to a
huge library of content from all of our
past guests so we greatly appreciate it
help support all of our work smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
you can follow the show at timcastirl
follow us on Instagram and you can
follow me at timcast uh do you want to
shout anything out at Alicia Krauss on
all on all social platforms Alicia
Krauss not Alicia cross Alicia Krauss
yeah we're gonna mess that up and uh
just so people know I have my own media
organization I released two videos today
one a daily news video and another very
important one about talking points that
you could share with your loved ones
when you're meeting with them over the
holiday season you could watch that one
exclusively on Luke uncensored.com hope
to see some of you guys there thanks for
having me you can always catch me at Ian
crossland.net check out my social media
accounts from there and I will see you
later
very wonderful spirited lady
conversation tonight I really enjoyed
your company Alicia thank you guys may
follow me on Twitter at Sour Patch Lids
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys